this is Jocko podcast number 164 with
echo Charles and me Jocko wellick good
evening echo good evening I crept ahead
a few feet and raised carefully to look
over the bank crack a rifle was thrust
up and fired only inches from Hales head
the bullet split his scalp and the
concussion broke his eardrums blood
streamed over his face blinding him and
I helped get him back to Stuart
then I pitched a second bomb close in
meanwhile McIntyre had not halted he had
rushed on that and sambro and I half
raised as we hurried after him
a machine-gun blazed at us from a spot
on the right and we dove into the mud
crash slam the Stokes gun was at work
but its shells dropped short falling
almost in our path we rose again as the
maxim stopped firing then a flaming
white-hot instant oblivion when I
recovered consciousness my head was
splitting with pain and a terrible
nausea seized my stomach the Stokes
shell had dropped beside me throwing me
bodily into the mud and sambro was
stunned as well he was lying in the
slime and feeling his limbs certain that
he was wounded all around us was a
frightful clamor of guns and bombs and
brightful shots
I heard McIntyre's voice shouting five
rounds rapid then it stops but my nose
was bleeding and I was too dizzy to
stand we crawled towards the sound then
halted there was a great plunging in the
murk and two dim figures came toward us
puffing and blowing tugging at something
they were Germans big men and a machine
gun and tripod they placed it just in
front of us and one man yanked it along
cartridge belt I pulled the pin from my
last bomb and heaved the missile at a
count of two it burst just beneath the
tripod one man went down like a huge
tree the other struggled a moment before
he stilled we went by them making sure
the gun was ruined and a new-made crater
found a man of a company with his wrists
almost severed
we bandaged him quickly and sent him
back and were rising to go on when Clark
came stumbling through the mud and
yelled at us come on give them his shout
was cut off he pitched dead in front of
us
the man scurried by with a stretcher and
we went over to the bank where we could
see men moving it was Lewis Gunnar and
he said MacIntyre had been shot through
the stomach and was dying they got him
on the old stretcher but he went on the
to the shore Bank in front and found old
bill Mickey and johnson crouched there
shooting in a German gun with that
Street sparks not more than thirty yards
away sambro had bombs with him and he
and I hurled them the burst seems right
it seemed right on the gun and it was
silenced I stared at the other men on
the bank they were all dead Melville and
IRA and Jennings lying there together
rifle in hand all shot through the head
by one sweep of the German gun old bill
had seen it and stayed there after
trying to pop the gunner himself the
fourth dead man was poor old Sam at rest
at last we looked around and found all
the rest of the party had gone but
another fit of sickness seized me and I
could not move for a long time
sambro stayed with me we did not go back
we had to crawl a distance to avoid the
machine gun fire but the main fighting
had shifted over to the left a light
vapor was stealing over the ground
making her harder to see and I stumbled
over a body as we found the road bank it
was the professor riddled with bullets
dead he was covered with mud had lost
his steel helmet had evidently got lost
in the darkness and there he lay after
years of study and culture with glassy
eyes and face upturned to the sky
a smashed cog of the war machine with
not a hope of burial excepting by a
chance shell and the mist thickened and
rolled suddenly over him night found us
still crouched in our cover and I got up
and went around the shell holes until I
found
bill and Johnson they told me that a
relief was due and that there had been
no orders then a corporal from another
platoon came and called to us to follow
him we were to go back to e pra's the
16th battalion was relieving us we went
and met the incoming men by our old
trench where were joined by the
remainder of the company and heard that
big Glen had been killed that is he died
gloriously in the fighting at the Graf
house all that long dragged back was a
hideous nightmare the track was worse
than when we had come and then the
shelling was in Sisson incessant we
moved with infinite slowness every step
a struggle a tearing physical effort and
a vast noise was all thundering rolling
clamor that dulled our thinking
mercifully some smothering some of our
agonized impressions of that night
before the November rains were chilling
us freezing us our feet were always
soggy and we were almost despondent all
that time we had been out we had talked
but little each man seemed busy with his
own thoughts disinclined to speak to one
another there had been too many of our
friends killed the men we had been with
for months I found that McLeod and
farmer had died in the mud angle Stone
had been wounded and placed on a
stretcher and then he and his bearers
were all blown to fragments by a big
shell and poor old Flynn had been killed
we seemed to move in a daze to do things
as if we were automotives when it grew
dark we moved again to form a new line
the Hun spotted us and started shelling
while machine-gun fire raked the ground
up him and I were together as we started
digging I saw a body just in front of us
a big man with his equipment over his
greatcoat
catch hold of that stiff I said to up
him pull him back here and we'll use him
for part of our parapet he stared at me
don't he yelled
don't touch him I seized the corpse
myself rolling it over into place and up
him sprang from where he'd been spading
and commenced our new hall over to the
right a salvo of shells came and
exploded
whizzing fragments were all around me
but I was not touched upon fell and was
dead when I reached him there was a
strange cry further on it was the
sergeant major who should have gone to
the depot the old original he and
insisted in coming in for one more trip
and his jaw had been carried away by
shrapnel he died before morning two
other men were down Johnson and Barron
both wounded the shelling continued all
that night and the next day we had dug
deep v-shaped pits connecting some of
them and there we crouched gray faces
under muddy helmets red-rimmed eyes
staring dazed wondering our brains
numbed beyond thinking by the incessant
explosions one of the new men pitched
down between our shelter and the next
one he was pierced in a dozen places and
one arm had been sheared from his body
by shrapnel
Mickey sat beside me shuddering half
stunned staring unseeing his limbs
twitching convulsively at each
concussion
and that right there is a couple of
pages worth of reading of the book and
we go on written by a guy by the name of
will Byrd who was a Canadian soldier
that fought in World War one and like I
said that's just a couple of pages from
the book but the pages go on and on and
on just like that war did and you you
really the amount of people killed
around him wounded around him it's it's
a horrific and it's hard to even fathom
what that did to these men before during
and after combat physically and mentally
and psychologically in the physical part
these are things that you can see you
can see those wounds you can understand
them but the psychological part is
perhaps the hardest to understand now I
say that this podcast is about human
nature and the reason it is and the
reason that I focus on human nature is
because I in my opinion in order to lead
people you have to understand people you
have to understand what their nature is
you have to understand human nature and
a lot of human nature boils down to
psychology and I recently got a
recommendation from a trooper out on the
interwebs who recommended a book called
psychology for the fighting man and this
is a book that was first printed in 1943
and the book is it's an incredible book
it's filled with an immense amount of
very useful in
nation and it's written has almost like
a mental guide to the American military
men that are getting ready to go fight
the Germans and the Japanese in World
War two obviously 1943 that's when it's
written this is right in the middle of
world war two and even though the book
is 75 years old the the information
that's in it the knowledge that is
contained inside of it can still be
utilized today in any leadership
situation and in fact this book is so
dense with information that I'm actually
gonna split it into two separate podcast
so that we can go into some more detail
and not end up with a 14-hour podcast so
let's kick it off going into this book
as I said the title of book is
psychology for the fighting man and the
subtitle is what you should know about
yourself and others it kicks off part 1
a psychology and combat when the British
Eighth Army pursued the retreating Axis
forces from Egypt through Libya they
found a long route correct they found
along the route great quantities of
abandoned equipment some tanks and guns
in perfect condition and gasoline for
the tanks and ammunition for the guns
the physical material of a large axis
force was there but it was useless to
the axis there were no men left to
operate it you keep hearing it said that
men cannot fight without weapons but it
is just a true that weapons cannot fight
without men an army is men not any men
at all for a crowd of men may only be a
mob but trained and equipped men what
sort of equipment do men of an army need
planes tanks guns and jeeps mortars
grenades rifles and bayonets camouflage
and muskets above all food and water
everything that the ordnance and
quartermaster can supply but that is
not all no the men need morale they need
courage they must have confidence in
each other and the belief in ultimate
victory
who is the quartermaster who can issue
stocks of courage and confidence yet
these are essential weapons so we're
starting off with a great point where do
you get your courage issued not from the
quartermaster not from the supply guy
no it's got to come from somewhere else
and it is just as important part of
winning a war as tanks planes bullets
and bombs going on and the army must
have leaders too plenty of them CEOs and
NCOs who supplies them besides leaders
it must have all sorts of special
abilities and skills mechanical
mechanical ability and in particular is
needed in this new mechanized war
ability to drive trucks pilot ability
mathematical ability cooking ability
clerks skills lots and lots of abilities
you can't fight a war without them the
army needs efficiency too and efficiency
means not only effective organization
there is also basic efficiency of the
individual man his strength and health
his resistance to hardship and fatigue
his alertness even when fatigued and
despite freezing cold or exhausting heat
toughness of body is a weapon
indispensable to victory this book is so
straightforward it's just so
straightforward and it doesn't pull any
punches mmm it's it's one of the best
things about this and you can tell it's
written it's directed it's directed for
like the font line grunt trooper that's
who it's directed at and not just the
infantry guy but anybody in the army in
doing any job and it's it's refreshing
to read something that's as
straightforward as this book is going on
the Army has a perpetual problem of
psychological logistics a problem of the
supply of motives and emotions of
aptitudes and abilities of habits and
wisdom
how does it get this mental material to
the right places at the right time that
is what this book is about so again it's
looking at the psychological aspect of
warfare and saying how do you how do you
deliver these necessary supplies we need
courage right we need abilities we need
emotions we need aptitudes we need the
right habits how do you deliver those
back to the book if the army cannot find
a man with needed ability an effort is
made to find one with an aptitude for
being trained in that ability and then
it trains them all in part by teaching
them the rules and the techniques in
part by giving them practice no troops
are ready to go into combat until their
training period is over and even then
they are still green troops the training
is still going on in combat until
finally the men are seasoned troops have
learned how to meet the unexpected
emergencies of war and have acquired
that competence and confidence that is
the basis of their courage it is this
human material that determines more than
any other one thing whether an army will
win or lose guns and chow are essential
to but given equally of supply victory
goes to the better troops troops
composed of men who know their jobs and
do them willingly and well men with
initiative to act by themselves the
trained troops which make up the
seasoned army there are more over
fundamental differences between people
that affect their ways of fighting and
their abilities to fight these
differences are not however due to blood
as the Nazis teach but mostly due to
training tradition home life and other
things that have a powerful effect on
the character of men war is waged best
by choosing methods of warfare best
adapted to the nature of our own people
and opposed to the nature's of the enemy
people's American men have no particular
love for killing for the most part they
hate killing
they think it is wrong sinful ordinarily
punishable by death they do not look
upon death as a beautiful and glorious
experience and most of them do not
consider the military life as a suitable
life work war to american men is a dirty
disagreeable business to be gotten over
as soon as possible so that we as a
nation can get along with what we were
happily engrossed in inventing producing
growing making life more useful and
satisfying Americans can stand a long
hard pull they look forward not back
they are slow to accept war will not go
all-out until they are attacked or are
sure their ideals are in grave danger
but once they have started they do not
stop or spare themselves until the goal
of victory seems to them to be secure
perhaps in 1919 they made a mistake
about having already made the world safe
for democracy but they would not have
stopped had they thought that they not
thought themselves safe nor will they
stop now they are not demoralized by
temporary adversity or single defeats so
some good info right there clearly
trying to set the mental attitude of the
American young American soldiers that
are reading this we can stand a long
hard pull if you mess with us we're
gonna finish it
we're not demoralized by temporary
adverse do your single defeats doesn't
matter you you want a battle right on
watch this we'll be back
continuing on it has been said that war
is inevitable that men are so made that
they just have to fight that is true if
you mean they have to be aggressive that
they need to have power and to use it
that they are forever wanting to change
things that are hard to change so as
that they can get on with better living
but the fact is that they do not have to
fight
each other and not many Americans agree
with Hitler in thinking fighting other
nations a good thing for any nation even
when the ugly ugly business ends in
victory there are other things than men
and nations to fight men can fight
calamity and disaster
flood fire and famine with anger and
zest and even fight nature to prevent
disasters happening
they fight disease having for a century
been waging effective war upon it with a
numerable conquest which history now
records they fight for freedom freedom
to worship as they wish
freedom to think and speak as they
please freedom from want and poverty
freedom from fear that's the American
and democratic philosophy the reason why
America is now at war every American
ought to understand this to know why a
nation that wants peace has to go to war
because nobody likes murder you have to
kill the murderers you cannot get along
without police and this war is a
policing job it's a large-scale job
because it is a total war
so clearly this book is is answering a
lot of questions for an
eighteen-year-old kid that's heading out
to war and maybe doesn't fully
understand why or what's happening and
here it is just laying it out look these
people are bad we're good they need to
wear the police of the world mmm
which sometimes in in today's time
people take that as a negative like one
can't be the world police yeah but here
you straight up this is straight up
saying yes we are the world police
there's bad guys we're gonna go put him
down and it's interesting too
nobody likes murder you have to kill
murderers mmm that's the way it's got to
be
again you know these days we get so
desensitized by media right by movies
and video games and music talking about
killing and I like that's just this is
the way we grow up mm-hmm but in in
these days you had to kind of convince
people that hey this is the way it's
gonna go down mmm
you're gonna go kill people and that's
okay total war is just what its name
implies war on all fronts with all
possible weapons there's the home front
as well as all the battle fronts there
are also the military front the economic
front and the psychological front
military economic and psychological
warfare makeup total war the Germans had
that big idea first
but the Americans can fight the devil
with his own fire and a hotter one and
are doing it the three kinds of warfare
are all related a military success may
also be an economic victory if it
results in the capture of great
quantities of enemy material or blocks
important supply routes to the enemy
nation or it can be a psychological
victory if it lowers enemy morale helps
to make soldiers expect to fiy leads the
enemy people to be ready to submit I
what I like about this idea of total war
is when you apply it to other parts of
your life right if you apply it to
business and how you can't just focus on
one aspect of business you can't just
focus on hey we're gonna go out and
create something new guess what we got
to create something new we got to sell
it
we got to figure out the way to get the
cost to produce down we got to figure
out how we're gonna beat our competitors
we got to figure how we're gonna sprint
you got to figure out all these things
total war in business in life total war
right how do you win the total your life
is war right your life is a war you're
fighting against all these things that
are happening and you're fighting to win
you're fighting to be healthy you're
fighting to be financially stable you're
fighting to take care of your family in
the best possible way it's Total War and
all these things you have to
fight all these fronts at the same time
all the time that's why you can't sleep
at night because it's total war in life
yeah so true so you can you can be like
winning certain battles in life you know
like you can have a great job making
great money but don't exercise to be
poor health yeah you know or opposite or
what there's so many like just accident
battles you know yeah absolutely
and you have to be paying attention to
those you have to pay attention all the
fronts yeah and there's a lot of times
where people get focused on one front
you know and it just doesn't it doesn't
help and even even like inside of a
business you'll get a business when they
just focus on one thing yeah and they'll
miss that they're getting flanked yeah
big time yeah a lot of those times and
this goes in life obviously that's what
how I'm thinking of it but I yeah in
companies right where you say they focus
so much on one thing and then a lot of
times is because that thing is like has
a big payoff you know like you get it
seems like dang I'm getting ahead huge
time especially like it like at home
right where let me just put in just a
few more hours of work right a week from
on too much three months and dang that
paycheck comes in and you do so well for
the come you go to work you're the hero
kind of thing and you're like dang I'm
getting ahead big-time
but like something else will kind of
falter which won't show itself right
away you know then when you like how you
seek it flank you're like dang Health
just flank you you got to get focused on
all fronts continuing on an economic
success of our own can lead to a
military defeat of the enemy if it robs
of him of essential supplies it can
become a psychological victory if it
disheartens him and makes him ready or
to give in on the other hand of course a
military victory is useless if it leads
to a psychological defeat the Japanese
may have done a great may have done
great military damage at Pearl Harbor
but it resulted in net loss to them
because the effect of uniting the
Americans in anger real defeat
other than death are psychological in
the end that's pretty powerful real
defeats other than death itself are just
psychological right so they're just
psychological the enemy gives up
surrenders you have to kill the enemy or
make him surrender there isn't any other
kind of victory if he is fanatical you
may just have to kill him
Americans would rather just get him to
surrender so this is something that's so
important to remember is that if you get
beat it's psychological if you're still
alive it's just a psychological defeat
you just need to reframe it and how are
you going to come back and win next time
psychological warfare is the newest arm
in war it is directed at opinion belief
confidence courage and the will to fight
it is both defensive and offensive for
it tries to build up morale in our
people and troops and to break down the
morale of the enemy the chief weapon of
psychological warfare is propaganda the
radio and the press are used to bolster
on the homefront the enemy has reached
by newspapers and leaflets dropped from
airplanes and by shortwave radio
propaganda in spite of what many people
think is not necessarily dishonest truth
is often the best propaganda especially
when it is fed to persons who are
starving for it
the most effective propaganda must be
founded on fact must start from some
important event that actually happened
and is known to be true then the
propagandist interprets the event much
as a good lawyer interprets evidence in
favour of his client or as the honest
advertiser makes a claim for his product
this is another very important part when
you're in a leadership position how much
of being a leader is making sure that
the propaganda gets out there have you
ever heard this expression when someone
says you know you're not really gonna
telling your story if you've heard that
before like a like a company they're out
there trying to do great things and they
are they're working hard and they're
having some success but nobody knows it
and I when I work with companies there
sometimes the companies no one even
inside the companies knows about the
successes that they're having they're
failing to even spread the word within
their own company mmm and so they think
they're getting you know crushed by the
by the competitors because they're not
because the competitors guess what the
competitors great at propaganda every
time the the the competitor signs a new
client they put out a big LinkedIn post
right they put in a big social media
blast hey we're just the sign oh it's
great - welcome aboard our newest client
meanwhile you know a company's not doing
that you know everyone inside the
company doesn't know that we're signing
all these new clients so this idea of
propaganda is is very important in
warfare huh and in leadership and in
business yeah and at the same time you
might have heard about this probably
have you know I think it was Facebook
maybe Instagram I forget but they did
like some study where it like it
actually was linked to people getting
depressed because of that and it's this
this constant that concept you just say
well you know people this is nothing new
where people they'll post just their
highlights of their life oh yeah and
then like me as just a normal person I'm
looking at everyone else's highlights of
their life thinking dang I don't live
that kind of life I'm not traveling to
Thailand you know you know all these
places and maybe I do but that was like
once last year and this you know I had
seen it so it kind of but that it's it's
like propaganda maybe on purpose oh
maybe not but it's like yeah it's like
that the perception you know where you
have you know your life and it's like
the highlights are like one out of a
thousand yeah well everyone else
seemingly is one out of one yeah just
all highlights out of another sushi
restaurant tonight yeah with a bunch of
girls oh yeah and it
Lamborghini you know we'll never give
you all that stuff man and it's like
everyone yeah except me
yeah also it's kind of that feeling like
Oh Charles he's not whatever I'm not
gonna fall for it not yeah no it's true
it's true and that stuff does it does
build-up it does and that's like
propaganda in your own life now believe
me I'm not recommending that you do good
propaganda all your hits to grab to show
your positive life no no I'm not saying
I'm saying don't believe the hype this
military psychology a psychological
warfare is not however the only way
which psychology contributes to success
in combat there are hundreds of others
and soldiers and officers need to know
what psychologists know and what
psychological methods can find out for
instance soldiers need to understand men
in order to understand themselves and
their comrades and officers must learn
how to interpret and influence the
conduct of those for whom they are
responsible so this is exactly what I
say all the time if you want to be a
good leader you got to understand people
the soldier must know about human needs
motives and emotions about fear when it
comes what to do about it about anger
when it is useful when it makes trouble
about zest which is the core of good
morale in a unit about anxiety and the
sense of insecurity about indignation
against the enemy and irritation against
comrades about the relation of food and
of sex to military life he should know
also of the relation of all these things
to morale and thus learn how to avoid
bad morale and to build up good morale
clearly and this is not just true for
combat this is true for life
every soldier ought to understand
further the problems of the mental
adjustment of men first to the army
later to combat why men feel insecure
what makes for courage the signs of
approaching breakdown how to prevent
breakdown and what to do about it when
it happens the selection and training of
leaders for the Army has become one of
the most important problems in the
psycho law in a psychology of war not
enough is known about it but what is
known to some should be known to all the
good leader is the man who builds up
morale how does he do it what kind of
man must he be if he is a poor leader
can he become a better one and there are
mobs and panics to be understood to
civilian mobs and panics may be the
concern of the soldier when the populace
gets mixed up with the fighting or when
the enemy's home front begins to break
panics may moreover occur in
well-disciplined troops if all the
conditions for panic are present what
are these conditions why are seasoned
troops panicked less than green troops
the army place each man with his talents
where he will be used to his best
advantage but each individual must know
how to get the most out of his talents
the primitive fact of combat is that man
pushes when he encounters an obstacle to
the achievement of his desire pushes
more if blocked gets angry of still
forwarded and then fights but to this
fighting he eventually brings all of the
knowledge and skill that has made him
supreme among the animals he fights by
learning how to use his eyes at night
and learning how to arrange a system
that will let him hear inside of an
airplane he fights by selecting good
leaders and good truck drivers he fights
by understanding human nature in order
to build up good
ow that will overcome fear
he fights by saying the right thing in
the right way to the right people at the
right time and sometimes that is
propaganda he uses every resource of
science and intelligence including
psychology he has to for this is total
war I love thinking about that never
every aspect of your life is to be
prepared for total war which by the way
you're in hmm you know you might not be
in combat at this moment in time but
you're fighting you're fighting all the
time and you have to bring every asset
every resource that you have available
you have to bring it to fight because
this is total war now the book goes into
some pretty big sections right here one
of them's site is a weapon or site as a
weapon and and then hearing as a tool
and it literally talks about how to see
better things you can do to make your
night vision better how to preserve your
night vision how to c-sharp or just all
those kind of things he talks about
camouflage and stuff real tactical stuff
and then it talks about hearing and what
you need to hear and how you can adjust
your hearing and how to listen sharply
and I'm gonna go I'm not gonna talk
about the sight piece but I'm gonna talk
about the noise there's just some
interesting points about noise loud
sounds especially when they are sudden
and strange are natural causes of fear
many sounds are terrifying a sudden loud
noise like the discharge of a pistol
will make anyone blink and jump it will
start with them this is true even if
well-trained men who pride themselves on
their familiarity with firearms it is an
instantaneous response that may be all
over before the eye can see it it shows
up however in slow motion pictures
seasoned troops get so that they don't
appear to pay any particular attention
to the din of
even horses will stand still under the
rising roar of a diving bomber will only
toss a head impatiently the experienced
soldier on the other hand needs first to
become adapted to the noises of war he
must be exposed to them in training as
much as possible after the noise has
become familiar its loudness will not
affect him so greatly in combat control
over noise makes it less fearful you
don't mind the noise of gunfire so much
as you are the one who is doing the
shooting so talking about getting people
used to the the loud noises that your
gonna come up against and this is
something that we used to do I don't
even know if guys do it anymore because
it's probably not that smart police do
immediate action drills with no ear
protection in so we get used to shooting
guns and having all that just massively
loud noise and we wouldn't do it every
time but we would do several runs with
no ear protection this is now in current
times guys have these nice headsets that
have noise there noise-canceling headset
so they're actually pretty awesome so
it's not that big of a deal anymore but
back in the day they wanted to make sure
hey you got to realize how loud this is
gonna be if you get in a firefight if
you get your first firefight and you've
never had a an m60 machine gun two feet
away from your ear keep getting crazy
laying down 100 round belts it'll be a
shock to your system so that's what and
and not to mention their Huck and you
know grenade simulators at you an
artillery simulator so there's
explosions going off because that's what
that's what they're trying to do get you
used to that scenario men subjected to
the excessive noise of war over a long
period sometimes build up an
oversensitive 'no sort of loud sharp
report they are in the state of a man
with a hangover the bang of a door will
make them jump a loud shout is painful
the noise of a truck exhaust is
frightening in the hospitals where men
are convalescing from bad cases of these
war nerves the dropping of a pan will
startle
a ward full of sleeping men so violently
that the jerk will bring them out of
their sleep and even out of their beds
and onto the floor but the state of
nerves the linked in their minds with
the noise and produced by the noise is
due mainly to more disturbing things
that have become associated with the
noise noises just as loud and originally
just as distressing as the noises of war
if they are only just a part of everyday
work or fun are tolerated men become
used to the din of a boiler factory or a
pneumatic drill it may defin them but it
does not demoralize them so that's
pretty obvious right what's what's
making these noises horrible to use
because every time a bomb goes off you
see your friends get blown up and killed
and you're afraid that the same thing is
gonna happen to you whereas a pneumatic
drill is just making a bunch of noise so
you're not that worried about it this
was again there's a lot of real basic
information you can imagine this book
being issued to frontline troops but I
had to call this one out here too sooner
or later
most soldiers have the experience of
getting lost in heavy woods or jungle
just possibly get lost a few yards just
a few Lagarde's off a trail it gives a
man a peculiar helpless feeling you are
so accustomed all your life to knowing
where you are and who you are and about
what time it is that the feeling of not
knowing one of these things comes as a
great shock and then it goes on a little
further it says a compass is a big help
yeah yes it is indeed there's another
real Captain Obvious it is best to have
a map in your pocket when you get lost
if you can't have one then you ought to
see one before you get into strange
country so that's real obvious too
the more a soldier knows about maps the
better equip he is for combat duty his
training and how to read them and what
to look for on them if he keeps
practicing it should enable him to find
himself if he ever gets lost on any
terrain he knows from maps the reason I
called that part out is think about all
the situations that you get in
where you have the opportunity to gather
some intelligence before you go into
them you know if you're going for a job
interview what can you know about that
company if you're going to meet with a
client you've never met with before how
much information can you have you these
days you can Google someone you get all
kinds of information you go to their
LinkedIn account you can find out where
they went to school and what sport they
play it or whatever you go to their
Facebook page you go to their you pull
up articles that were written about them
and there's all kinds of intelligence
you can gather there's no reason to go
into a meeting blind anymore
without knowing the terrain that you're
getting into without understanding the
culture that you're going into there's
no reason for it next work in the army
is much more than just shouldering a
rifle and doing long foot marches
soldiers work at several hundred
different kinds of fighting jobs and at
even more kinds of job some directly
related to combat and some not which can
be filled with men already trained for
them or men who have the necessary
aptitude for learning one of the jobs
quickly all leaders have the
responsibility for seeing that the right
man gets the right job and when mistakes
are made that misfits are transferred
and this thing is this where this book
gets pretty politically incorrect it's
basically saying look some people can't
do this jobs some people aren't fit for
these jobs and some people aren't fit
for these other jobs continuing on
thousands know how to drive a tractor
how to repair an ignition system others
can weld castings repair watches other
timing instruments or Road transits keep
accounts carve carcasses of beef
developed photographs the army needs
many men who can do these things the
British found that out in the first
world war at first they neglected to
save their specialists they sent to the
front professional men engineers and men
in skilled trades many were killed in
the early months of the war later the
need for them in special posts behind
the line became acute so yeah this is
all about forming up an army of
civilians that have skills and saying oh
you've been a truck driver for whatever
four six years in the civilian sector
guess what you're gonna do for us you
I Drive a truck oh you're a butcher
guess what we need butchers and right on
down the line and you can imagine World
War 1 probably them that being very
short-sighted on how long that war was
gonna last it let go oh you're a
mechanic cool we're just gonna send you
the front with everyone else and you're
gonna die like everyone else and you
look up in six months or a year and they
don't have the necessary support
logistically to carry on the war how
soldiers differ men differ just as much
in ability to learn different sorts of
duties as they do in size of feet in
height or in weight some are as much as
three times as able as others I like
that a some people are just three times
more capable than you that's the way it
is most of course are just about average
some men cannot learn a through a3
figure telephone number by hearing at
once some can learn as many as nine
figures the average is around six or
seven have you ever heard that before
have you ever heard that the reason our
numbers are seven digits long is because
that's about the average that a human
can memorize no I haven't and that's
very interesting
I heard that could that possibly be not
bro science but urban Marisa could it be
a legend it could be it's true I like it
yeah it's awesome actually well you well
you have your doctorate in bro science
so what more can i yes yes you did you
do your undergrad in urban legend
back to the book some men starting from
scratch can learn in eight weeks to
receive and send radio code at sixteen
words per minute it takes others 22
weeks some men used to handling certain
types of machinery can learn to handle
certain kinds of weapons much faster
than others so the problem is to
understand and measure aptitude aptitude
his potential skill the capacity for
learning to do something quickly and
accurately when given the chance to
learn both speed and accuracy are
important in learning a soldier needs to
learn rapidly but also to be accurate at
what he's learned and men different
differ from one to another in both ways
for one thing men differ greatly in the
speed with which they learned some
aviation cadets can solo solo after 4
hours of instruction others are not
allowed to solo even after 14 hours here
the quick learners are urgently needed
slow learners tie up the training fate
planes to long
besides quick learning might mean a
shorter war yet the armory cannot do
without the slow learners manpower is
needed and there are many military jobs
which require other qualities than speed
of learning jobs which the slow learners
will prefer to have men also differ in
speed and accuracy of reaction the
average driver requires from 1/2 to 3/4
of a second to put on the brakes after
the stop light goes red yet some can
apply the brakes in three tenths of a
second others use up to a whole second
these are important differences for
riflemen and machine gunners as well as
for truck drivers every tenth of a
second counts in battle you ever see
that thing when they were they were
doing like the speed tests for Conor
McGregor then he was the fuze the
fastest athlete they had tested speed
like reaction
they'll be like reaction time like when
you see something you touch a button or
whatever you know whenever they have
these little tests set up yeah then
apparently McGregor was the fastest
athlete that they had tested which is
easy yeah it is crazy
yeah it is crazy because you know some
of these baseball players and I guess I
think I think that would be the do you
think that would be the fastest eye and
eye coordination yeah yeah the top of my
head seems like it because those balls
come quick yeah yeah yeah there is a
test you can do when we're kids wow they
do it you know in science class and you
hold on a real you know they you get a
ruler oh yeah and they drop it one yeah
the teacher holds it and then you puts
it on your finger you know between your
fingers right at them at the zero mark
yeah drops it how quick you can how far
do your fingers have to be opened I
don't know because it seems like that
could be an advantage my grandfather he
used to do this
Louise called the dollar drop okay then
he would fold the dollar lengthwise only
to make it kind of aerodynamic and if
you could catch the dollar you could you
could keep it okay yeah it sounds pretty
easy doesn't it yes sir it does some
people can't catch that dollar but yeah
yeah so you'd think if you're you know
how you're saying you just said how far
your fingers yeah the thing is for the
experiment as long as you designate kind
of that you know or even eyeball it ya
know it might be a millimeter different
but you know usually it's like it's but
there's always those people that look at
that edge right yes because I'm thinking
I would be figuring out how I used to do
that with a dollar drop right I'd get my
fingers here yes that makes sense when
they you know the dollar drop has more
stakes for sure plastics even though yes
sir pulls out that fiber you're really
the guy in science class who wanted to
win though even though it wasn't a
competition of course it's a competition
so in I don't know I'm pretty sure that
that stuff can be trained as well and
that's one thing that you know we when
you're bringing your kids up you bring
them up and you make them play multiple
different sports you don't focus I'm too
young because they become they don't
they don't develop for the broader
athletic skills so you're supposed to
get them involved in a bunch of
different sports and those kids will end
up even if you took one kidding you say
oh you're just gonna do 100% football
this whole life and you took another kid
you did multiple sports and but you did
like a little bit more of a focus on
football the chances are the kid that
did multiple sports but focused on
football is gonna do better than the kid
that just did football from what I
understand I'm sure there's some bro
science people out there that will
object to my statement makes sense you
know when it's brought more broadly
athletic yeah like you can and pretty
I'd imagine you'd be able to learn
quicker too because your body is used to
moving you know different ways rather
than just allowing and house what are
you to do with things are a little bit
different out on the football field
right yeah there's little situations
that can unfold it if you're a that
eclis adept at adapting to various
situations you're gonna be better off
yeah it's true going on men differ also
in the speed and accuracy of perceiving
one clerk can check in five minutes a
company roster that takes another man 20
minutes some men can see a white target
in the dark 400 yards away to others it
is invisible at 200 yards range finders
differ in their ability to tell the
distances of different objects when the
job is seeing you must choose the best
seers so that's interesting cuz you can
have someone that has bad reactions but
they see really well and if you ever
read I'm sure at some point will do
Chuck Yeager's Buccaneer matter-of-fact
Chuck Yeager's on Twitter
I don't know if you know that but Chuck
Yeager's on Twitter and I've gone back
and forth a couple times people have
said come on the podcast but in his
podcast or his book Yeager
he just had incredible vision like he'd
be flying in formation and he could see
the enemy mm way before anyone else
could see the enemy he'd be like up
bogeys at 4 o'clock boom we go and
because his eyesight was apparently just
amazing and that used to be a big deal
for fighter pilots I think it's less of
a big deal now because you got radar and
all that so it's not as big of a deal as
it used to be just your eyes against the
enemy's eyes back to the book there is
however much more to a good soldier than
speed and accuracy with which he learns
acts and perceives every man has
interests likes and dislikes these
determine in part what he will do well
and how fast he will improve a man's
interests for instance for instance
usually determine what he will do with
what he learns mere exposure to training
never made a skilled soldier it is the
interested man who remembers and profits
by his training and is ready to apply it
to new situations right so just so true
how true it's just so true so true we
don't and and what I think is really
important about this from a business
perspective is what they're basically
saying is put the right people in the
right jobs that's the overall concept to
put the right people in the right jobs
that's what you need to do if you've got
someone that might not be super talented
but there's very interested they're
probably the better hire than someone
that's just got a bunch of talent that
doesn't care in fact I'll go ahead and
say they straight-up are the bedrock
yeah yeah cuz and then they'll they'll
wind up learning like so quick and your
specific thing yeah you know you're
supposed to they're they're into it yeah
if someone that's not into it that's
that's bad oh like someone who has like
a major like degree and you know his
resumes degree
like hey I'm really into whatever it is
that you're doing like for instance you
like making videos you're into it right
sure if you didn't like make you know if
you got no enjoyment from it
think of how horrible it would be to
trying to get you to do it me it's
pretty hard to get you to do video right
now and you actually like doing it yeah
or you know like um like politics right
you know how like some people they like
politics some people don't so you get
someone who likes politics and the news
comes on they're gonna be all up in
there
learning everything what's going on like
today you know then someone who's not
there like all the news is on let me
watch yeah yeah you know well that's it
interesting I thought you were to say
that people that are in the public
because I actually oh that's one case
where I would disagree cuz a lot of
times people that really like politics
you don't want them in politics because
they're just political machines right
you want a normal person oh yeah yeah
just a normal everyday you don't want
the person that's like you know what I'm
gonna be President
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be in charge they
like that person you don't really be
President yeah yeah I think it's like
look I don't really want to do this yeah
and I think the other that's different
because that's all hungry for the
political life they're they're they're a
arrogant person that thinks that they
should be in charge of anything now yeah
I don't like on TV like so like me if I
if I watch I don't know like okay so
well that's kind of a good example
because I'm interested in Hawaii so you
know I'm like but like okay so on so I
make videos right it is some some visual
effects or whatever there's a YouTube
channel called Video Copilot right so
all it's mainly just tutorials on how to
do stuff that's all it is really so when
that like if a new video comes out of
something man I'm all up in there all up
in it but you don't care right you're
gonna watch that thing and you're gonna
you're gonna you're not even gonna click
on it not even close though unless I was
like I wonder if I want to take echoes
job yeah or okay okay case in point I'm
not interested right so I could barely
even get through
one of those video that's where I'd be
like now I'm gonna go over here and do
burpees yeah exactly so you're gonna
click on that video if I say hey jogo
click on this video this will make you
know you're broaden your horizon I don't
know whatever click on this video and
just watch the whole thing watch it five
times actually yeah but when you're done
watching it five times it's bad
everything went over your head don't
care you don't even care so advice from
this book is put people that are
interested in the job
truly inherently interested and they're
gonna do a better work even then maybe
someone that's more talented than then
they are back to the book other personal
differences besides interests and likes
and dislikes are important especially
for some military tasks one may feel one
man may feel completely at ease in the
transparent cage in which a Bombardier
must sit while another ordinarily
dexterous is so upset in the exposed
position that the pupils of his eyes
dilate his fingers fumble and he cannot
manipulate the bomb site properly so
there you go you got a guy that's
probably a better maybe he has quicker
reaction times but he's just scared to
be inside the turret yeah two equally
wise officers may not be equally good
leaders one is at ease with his men
talking with them freely getting their
slant on matters of importance and
giving his orders and directions readily
the other although he wants his men to
like him and respond alertly and
willingly to him as a leader cannot
bring himself to feel free and confident
with them and open up with them in a way
to gain their confidence and liking in
turn the first is of course the better
leader so there you go that's like
straight up hey this person if you're
more comfortable talking to your troops
they're gonna sense that and you're
gonna be better than someone that's not
comforted
talking to the troops mm-hmm indeed
leadership is the quality that the army
most needs all advancement brings with
it responsibility and responsibility for
the conduct of others requires
leadership that's interesting because
what's interesting about that is that is
and it goes into this later on talking
about the we probably won't cover until
the next podcast on this book but
talking about the you know our leaders
born or made
and this is clearly leaning a little bit
towards born clearly which I agree with
I think leaders are born and made yeah
but it feels like a lot of times when
people use the expression are they born
whether it be leaders will it be
whatever you know he's a natural
whatever um I get the expression and I
understand and I didn't agree of course
but technically like if you say if a
leader is made or born born meaning like
he wasn't trained at a very specific
point to be a leader he brought to the
training or to the position just a bunch
of like talent or whatever but he
probably learned that through like his
life what he was exposed to what he was
in true but there are certain aptitudes
that people have and those playing him
back if you have somebody that's really
articulate they're gonna make a better
writer than someone that's not hurt but
even someone who's articulate they learn
that through sort of life is know
possibly but some of it maybe there's
like a shorter tongue or something I
don't know if there's an articulate gene
there is an articulate gene for sure and
well it's not a gene it's your brain how
much capacity do you have the process
words quickly and assemble them together
into sentences and put them out to a
comprehendible statement how can you do
that how well can you do that yeah but
you're not boring at it I guess yeah it
is like a process you have the yeah you
what yeah that's it what processor what
size processor do you have in your in
your brain
you got the old 486 not wise or you've
got a new an tiem whatever you know it's
like the i7 or i9
I have no idea anyway but no because
there's articulate people who don't talk
fast
or tone yeah yeah yeah you're able to
assemble there okay here's another one
and this one's and I've talked about
these before but the ability to look at
complex problems and simplify them yeah
sure some of that is learned some people
just are born with it mmm some people
learn it in the streets
yeah I think my I'm trying back on my
bro science background yeah I do think I
believe I'm under I believe it all it's
a belief that you get it from like like
like your I love it but I guarantee if
you take someone that had a twin brother
yeah and and you one of them would be
more apt at some things than the other
one there's got to be some things that
you are better at than your brother
naturally and some things that your
brother is better at than you I don't
know of any but I mean put it this way
all the differences that we have I feel
like I can map it back to why because
just being second born I was born a
little bit smaller to not look at me
like a bigger come I don't give you good
especially people would compared to you
know like growing up with a twin brother
they always compare anyway the point is
I'm not saying I'm not saying you're I
think you for you're probably right of
course but I think it's mostly learned
bro people have a certain genetic
cognitive capacity without question yeah
that's not even debatable yes I would
not to be so what we're talking about is
the ability to take that cognitive
capacity and steer it towards the
articulation of language
which if you have more cognitive
capacity you'll be able to articulate
language better and there's probably
little modules inside the brain that
aren't genetic that have even more
capacity for the grabbing and assembling
of linguistic patterns together where
they flow off the tongue
rapidly and sensibly and there's got to
be part of your brain that's better at
that just genetically now of course if
you spend a lot of time in that arena
you will get better at it over time but
there's gotta be some just like you have
X amount of fast twitch muscle and echo
Charles like how hard did you work at
your vertical jump
did you guys test that in football yes
okay what was the highest vertical jump
you ever had 39 okay that's pretty good
right is there a were there people on
your team that worked harder than you if
not harder that never got to 39 and a
half inches probably yes actually yes
yeah because I don't really work exactly
I knew this is a loaded question
so yes sir so somewhat there was someone
on your team that they they worked and
they trained and they were doing jumps
Watson you know garyun lunges and split
squats and they were just trying to get
that vertical jump up they were weird
remember those shoes with like those on
them get them hops
want to get them hops so this guy had
all those things and you know he got to
32 inches right he was bummed yeah but
but that's what I'm saying yes he has a
certain genetic capability there's
physical capabilities that are genetic
and there's some some mental
capabilities that are genetic and both
of them have a max capacity and that
dude that width of the toe shoes for
vertical jump improvement at warm
awesome there was a kid one time he
lived across the street from me he you
know he's young he was this is when I
was probably 25 hours and the games back
in the day
but this kid trained all summer long
yeah with those shoes and he what he
wanted to do is dunk a basketball yeah
and he did it he did it eventually but
he worked hard there are some people
that don't even have to work hard they
can dunk a basketball
they're just got it yeah man I say yeah
man my friend cake nuts who I mentioned
Ken cake nuts don't know we're talking
about some different attribute now he
was he always had like kind of like big
it's called big muscle bellies like the
party or muscle anyway he had kind of
big muscles genetic he was a thinner guy
but and he was always cut so even into
adulthood he wouldn't have to watch his
diet and you know meanwhile I feel like
a normal person if you watch your diet
like a lot then you can get that cut you
didn't get there oh yeah totally can but
cake nuts it's just cruising just ABS
you know and then he like lists a bunch
of weights over the summer who's work on
I gave him by the way
and he lists but he comes back and he's
just huge still got by the way so it's
like dang but you know he just has it
like that there you go I think genetic
genetic differences and that's what
they're talking about in this book and I
think sometimes people's attitude
nowadays is like well you know you you
can do whatever you want
well to know actually you should find
out what's good for you yeah that's what
you should look for yeah like I was a
radio man you know it's like a radio man
why cuz I was like smart but I was big
enough to carry a radio right yeah if
the small guys in the seal platoon they
become the point man because you don't
have to carry any extra weight general
that's so you're so right like so right
and consider like major industries and
we'll just say sports right where it's
like it's pretty clear when you win you
win when you lose you lose sports all
right so get the established sports with
very very few exceptions is gonna be the
case you're gonna get like okay football
because there's a bunch of positions
that do very different things
the tight end he's gonna be a certain
bill generally Swisher the quarterback
he's gonna be a certain build into the
receiver he's gonna be a certain build
the center and the line certain bills
like you grab a guy from a line guard
right one of the guys in the line you
with him on defense as like a cornerback
or something
who needs literally opposite you know
should do that see what happened so no
no no just train them train them for ten
years no negative probably make them
better but yet make him successful
exactly right so it's like it's such a
clear example just because there's more
on the line with that you know so if
you're a youngster you should look at
your attributes and see number one where
your attributes fit and then what your
interests are sometimes people get
they're super interested and so they
just try for it anyways yeah you know
and that's yeah that's cool there's
there's some people that would get
really good at a sport but they're still
not good enough to go pro because they
don't have the genetic yeah and gifts
that's are needed yeah and that's why
it's so prevalent and such a like big
deal when you do find they're like the
super rare guy where it's like hey he's
not really genetically gifted but he
works so hard that he made it in the
ocean and absolutely that's like a guy
in basketball who's like not tall not
fast yeah you know like the knots and
legs
yeah but he was he was pretty fast
though and he could jump well but he's
small yes you know what's interesting
I was talking to Dallas who's the coach
of the gulls the San Diego girls hockey
team but a few years ago not very long
the hockey had become all these big
giant guys you know six four six five
260 pounds these big monster guys and
that's where everyone had started going
in that direction all the team there's
getting bigger makers these guys are
massive where they could hit hard and
then recently it started going back
again to guys that were smaller and
quicker and could move faster so that's
an interesting evolution but you can
look at it you could have looked at it
you know four years ago or whatever was
I don't really know but ten years ago or
whatever when if you were five eleven
you're like ah man I'm not big enough to
play pro hockey but some kids were like
you know what I'm five-eleven be fast
and move faster than everyone okay cool
and they made it yeah and now they're in
the game
make sense yeah I'm not as familiar with
like the necessities of being a good
hockey player or team as far as the
physical attributes but like football
use that be that example because the the
jobs of each position are so different I
meant not each position but like the
differences between you know like a
cornerback wide receiver and then the
difference between that and like a yeah
so like basketballs different even
though they have different positions
where everyone happened to score that
I'm generally speaking of course it's
exceptions but everyone's gonna be tall
no one's gonna be like slow if you're
like slow it's like that's a big kind of
deal you know so everyone's a little bit
more uniform yeah hockey seems the same
way yeah more uniform hockey's more
uniform seal platoon is not uniform you
got a big 60 gunner really big gunner
yeah but but you know what not all paid
Gunners are big because you can just be
a tough 162 pound pig just kinkle just
get just kid grind it out yeah point man
it's usually a little bit smaller but
that's but when you get to a SEAL team
guys looking you're like oh you're
you're five seven you're 140 pounds beer
to be appointment that's the way most
the time sometimes you get in a platoon
and they're like we already got a point
man dude you're gonna carry a pig here
you go buck up and start doing some
squats all right personality it takes
more than brains to make a good soldier
it takes guts it takes endurance it
takes a willingness to do hard work it
takes a keen interest in doing the job
well
psychologists wish they could give the
army right now a method of measuring
these important personality assets tests
that would be as accurate and reliable
as a test for measuring the ability to
do arithmetic or aptitude for learning
radio code they can't some tests have
been tried many have been found useless
few are promising you know it's
interesting I just thought of this I
went to communication school the the
seal communication school and we need to
learn more
code and there was was probably 20 guys
in my comms course and we all had to
learn Morse code and this was very clear
that some people were better at it than
others because you had to and we didn't
have to send very fast we but we had to
be able to receive oh yeah like a
certain amount of groups it's called a
group it's five five letters in a group
and they would just come out 2d 2dbb DB
and you had to be able to receive and
write down what the letters were yeah
with no mistakes but what's interesting
is we all showed up no one knew any
Morse code when we showed up and there's
a complete bell curve when we got done
you know some guys were really good at
it naturally some guys were horrible at
it and it took every ounce of mental
power for them to figure out and get to
be able to pass the test and I had a
crazy guy that was teaching the comm
school and someone be like hey chief why
do we have to learn you know Morris code
since no one uses it anymore he needs a
ax in the event of a nuclear holocaust
Morse code is the only thing that's
gonna be punching through the ionosphere
and of course I was 18 years old I was
like all right you know my interest was
piqued I was okay in the event of a
nuclear holocaust I'm gonna be on the HF
radio hammer and out Morris code to the
Troops let him know what's up stupid I
was mean so what you don't agree that
dude if there's a nuclear holocaust I
wouldn't be alive well why don't you be
dead but you you know what if you're
like one of the only survivors or
survivors like me but it's so that man
that's interesting that that where you'd
have to have that small little thing
that you just said where you have to
it's less about putting it out it's more
about receiving because worse code you
don't communicate necessary here's a
figure so when you come to here's the
reasoning behind it if you want to send
Morse code you can send it with a piece
you want yeah the people are just gonna
sit there and take letters that you're
sending right they're not saying hurry
up so you can send it whatever pace you
want but receiving you got to be
I forget what the minimum standard I
think I want to say it was Toni groups a
minute or something like that yeah
wants to pass you mean like not passing
and I forget I forget but we weren't as
good as like a regular Navy guy who
would just be I don't even know what but
they were way faster we were
knuckle-draggers compared to them
they're like Al and we had to learn
every day you had to do it every day
until you test it out and some people
test it out in a few weeks some people
didn't test out until the you know the
last days Morse code um do you still
know Morse code not really what if he
came in at like beep yeah I would need
to brush up on it yeah and brush up on
it and which I need to do because if
there is a nuclear holocaust yeah I want
to be know ready to get coms out HF coms
yeah and receive him of course you know
yeah but it's such a clear example of
and the guys it wasn't like on that bell
curve of guys that were good and bad it
wasn't like everyone that was a good
seal was up at the top and the guys that
weren't good at Morse code were bad
seals no it was like some of the guys
were awesome guys and they sucked at
Morse code yeah and some guys were
marginal guys but they were great at
Morse code yeah and there's a perfect
example like what do you do with that
guy won't put him in a make him a radio
man you know yeah interesting
yeah cake that's what he when he was
going through I think his but no knows
how it is after but he he kept saying
like man actually my other friend Jeremy
was telling me that oh yeah he's good at
like pretty much everything yes he's
just really good at stuff except for
picking locks yeah it was like
struggling with like your locks which is
kind of a random thing to struggle with
picking boxes is a difficult thing and
it's uh it's more like playing a musical
instrument that it is like doing a
technical skill where you do a B C and
you get D no picking locks is like
you're gonna have it all you little art
and got a feel for it and I've been with
guys I was okay at picking locks the guy
that I learned from was he could walk up
and put the you know walk up to a
doorknob and stand not facing it and
just stand there and just pick the lock
open
seconds it's pretty incredible kind of
like on that movie The Italian Job you
ever watch that no yeah it's a good one
so no this girl she was like the
safecracker
right you know they're like a den of
thieves there this group so she's the
safecracker and guess what her dad was
massive cracker you know so it was like
a genetic thing they're good you know so
she the dad passed it on to the you know
it's like genetic some people that's all
you know yeah
maybe they learned behavior as well that
she's known from the oh man all right
going on back to the book one trouble is
that a man's person as is important one
trouble is that a man's personality
changes in different situations for
instance the man who is brave as a lion
in the test room at a reception center
may not be so brave when he gets into
combat the man who is able to make quick
decisions wisely when things are quiet
may go to pieces when he is distracted
by machine-gun fire and do something
that result in his own death or the
death of others and difficult situations
may have the reverse effects on some men
men who have never distinguished
themselves in training camp may become
fired with new spirit when going when
the going gets tough astounding
themselves and other men with what they
can do in extreme emergency so that's
obviously important too so even though
you know someone you don't even know him
you don't know what you're gonna get you
might have somebody that freaks out when
things go sideways next section training
makes the soldier when men enter the
army they're told the importance in the
fighting areas of taking cover from
enemy fire in slit trenches this point
is emphasized in books lectures training
films demonstrations and exhibits by the
time the soldier reaches the battle zone
he has learned that he should take cover
in a slit trench whenever he stops that
is one kind of learning in one way it is
the most useful kind with knowledge of
how things should be done and why they
are important a soldier's equipped to
act in new situations and there is
nothing that produces so many new
situations as combat but this kind of
learning unfortunately does not always
result in action a soldier may know
perfectly well that he should dig a
trench you may have learned it from
demonstrations exactly
how to go digging it yet when the enemy
planes come overhead he may and his
excitement forget that what he was
learned in such emergencies he is more
likely to act from habit than from
reasoning and since habit formation is a
further stage of learning it depends on
practice experience and repetition no
action ever becomes automatic by
learning in words how to perform it but
without actually practicing it but by
repetition the operation of a machine or
a rifle gets itself reduced to habits so
that it becomes almost entirely
mechanical like walking you do not have
to think about putting your left foot
forward after planning your right foot
ahead that is because you'll walk so
much you could do you could not get that
way merely from listening to lectures on
how to walk if during maneuvers a
soldier practices taking cover instantly
whenever he sees her here's an air
attack warning or plane coming close he
if he always throws himself flat when he
first hears this sudden whistle of a
shell or the singing of bullets past his
ears these actions soon becomes second
nature to him the particular warning
sights and sounds become fixed as
signals for immediate actions in real
emergency the soldier does not have to
stop and think about what he should do
he just does it straight forward that's
why we roll in jiu-jitsu
that's why look drilling is important I
get it you got to learn the move but you
got a roll yeah why and one could argue
that drilling it serves the same purpose
just in a more like specific it does so
it does you got to do both yeah yeah now
if you drill correctly but what you
can't do is sit there and get shown to
move right you got to do the move yeah
and I used to do that too and we'd have
guys going through CQC training and a
lot of times you know instructor might
want to hear himself talk a lot and
explain things because you know it's
it's a pump to the ego when you get up
there and you show people what's what
sure how I did it
after Julian did it like this so you
know you an instructor that wants to
hear himself talk and meanwhile they sit
there and talk for 20 minutes the seal
platoon could have done three more runs
through the kill house in 20 minutes so
I'll tell you what say what you got to
say say it quick and let the boys go
pull that trigger that's how we get good
by doing back to the book this sort of
learning of minor importance in high
school or college is basic in the Army
that is why drill is so important why
discipline is so essential in wargames
the soldier gets conditioned to all
sights and sounds of battle in early
training it may be possible to simulate
realistically the noises of shells dive
bombers and bursting bombs by recordings
reproduced by loud speakers in advanced
training a soldier may be taught to lie
flat on the ground while real bullets
strike within a few feet close enough to
cause sand to fall on the back of his
neck he knows he is safe as so long as
he lies still but if you should get up
and run he will be killed that is good
training for combat a real bullet forms
much better habits than a lecture about
a bullet such thoroughly drilled habits
enable the soldier to act when there is
no time for thought they ensure that he
will act correctly and mechanically even
when his mind is confused and thinking
is almost impossible but knowledge of
the science of warfare and practice in
solving novel military problems are
important too because they enable the
soldier to act wisely in the thousands
of unexpected emergencies that arise in
battle habit is safer than fought for
standardized acts but it won't work for
brand-new problems that is why we would
train our guys in brand new problems all
the time that way you get a protocol for
how to how to handle brand new problems
you start to understand what your gonna
do I don't know what's happening what am
i new is step back I'm going to look
around I would assess the situation I'm
gonna come up with some possible
solutions I'm gonna think about what the
outcomes of those solutions are what the
risks are and then I'm gonna make a
decision we're gonna move forward in
that direction because like
confronting or dealing with new problems
or uncharted situations or whatever the
skill of dealing with that is like
another skill isn't of itself like I
think you're saying this in class yeah
protocol and people are asking about
protocol protocol for handling new
problems yeah and eventually you get
good at because of lately obvious the
first things you do is Evie cache you
have to take a step back you have to
turn her and look around physically look
around so detach look around make an
assessment come up with possible
solutions think about what the outcomes
of those solutions might be and then
pick the one that has the best possible
outcome pretty different than like
trained level 10 training yeah her
perfect training on situation ABCD efg
hijk LMNOP yeah and cute cuz you but
you're gonna get hit with Z yeah one Z
it's it's like dang King and then you
totally should I just got a message from
a guy that was a police officer there's
a big firefight with some of his guys
and he was literally said said I was
like thinking to myself okay cover move
here's what we're gonna do prioritize
and execute he was going through he's
like it was pretty awesome pretty
awesome to hear guys say yep I could
hear your voice saying cover move put
down cover fire right now yeah well they
were in a twenty one minute firefight
which is along to law that's a long
firefight for especially for police
officers back to the book drill for
combat changes the recruit squad into an
efficient fighting machine training can
convert an unorganized civilian group
into an organized unit with deadly power
military confident competence moreover
strips war of its most repulsive and
paralyzing horrors and knowledge takes
from the enemy his most potent potent
and effective wet weapon surprise drill
combat training practice and discipline
combined with the experience in war are
things that make America's combat troops
into seasoned troops so even taking away
the ability for the enemy to surprise
you it's like we talked about before
if if you try and move on me and jujitsu
and I've never seen it before there's a
chance it's gonna there's the best
possible chance gonna work as soon as I
know what that move is then it's the
chances of it working are a lot less a
lot less significantly less yeah yeah
that's why role playing is so important
well in the business world yeah is very
important because we can come at you
with different things that are
subordinate it's gonna save you yeah or
even up the chain of command if I had to
go brief my boss on something that we
were pretty sure he didn't like and I
was like okay I go you be the boss you
come at me with all the negatives about
the plan I've come up with and then we
do that so then I go in
I've already seen these don't ya even
one time like I said one one time makes
an incredible difference back to the
book and we need speed democracy's
always have to hurry up at the last
minute the enemy is always facing us
ready trained and there isn't much time
we must take advantage of every possible
shortcut toward the goal of creating
seasoned troops troops armed with
adequate adequate training the first
shortcut is an understanding of the few
facts about how learning takes place the
most important requirement of learning
is incentive men marching to drill
reluctantly can no more be taught
swiftly and efficiently than a jeep can
be taught to run on an empty tank people
need incentive but fortunately for the
Army's instructors there is a powerful
there is a powerful motive furnished by
the situation itself
no false incentives need be thought up
and provided the enemy has attacked us
we are at war and no man wants to go out
and face the enemy unprepared no
American wants to see American soldiers
killed needlessly in unmatched battle no
one wants to see our armies defeated and
the Gestapo policing New York City
success itself is a reward to the
soldier it makes him proud this is when
they start I forgot to say that I'm
skipping jokes at this book but this is
where he's talking about how the
incentives that
that a soldier can have his commander
may commend him but is usually enough if
he sees that a co has noticed that he
has done a good job good morale depends
on such rewards a probe such awards by
his officers and approval from his own
comrades in general reward is much more
effective for learning than his
punishment this is good punishment
excites resentment intends to make the
soldier anxious not to comply if he can
get away with carelessness or
disobedience that's if you could
remember that right there this podcast
is worthwhile if you remember the fact
that as a leader if you're if you're
constantly punishing people what you're
doing is it making them resentful
encouraging them to not comply and
rebell against you and try and get away
with carelessness and disobedience think
about your dad still right because we do
that with the kids you better do what I
told you and they try they're trying to
skate around you reward keeps his
attention on the business in hand
punishment tends to shift his attention
from the task to his own troubles the
best kind of reward because his most
effective and learning is the glow of
satisfaction that a man has when he
knows he has done something correctly
and well it has clicked the most
effective punishment is the surge of
disgust that comes when he knows he's
missed the target thought no one's
always good to have a reminder because
it's natural to like with your kids or
whatever the when they do something
wrong it's because that'll stick out
more in your mind you know if they do
something right especially if it's not
for the first time it's like oh yeah
that's how you're supposed to do it
right kind of things so it doesn't stick
out as you want you to commend them yeah
like encouragement reward kind of thing
like it's you know it's more powerful
but then in your mind as kind of the
teacher or whatever the when they fail
to miss the mark you know especially if
they do it like if they're having a hard
time with something you know you know
like to learn stuff you got to do it
over
then they're having a hard time I don't
know swimming potty-trained on whatever
when they don't miss the mark yet so you
it comes with a frustration sometimes
can't do that can't show that kind of
thing but even though it's like the most
readily available like reaction you know
the when they fail so you got so yeah to
be reminded of it helps I think yeah
it's an important point next this is why
the Army has to has been right to reduce
greatly the emphasis on close order
drill in recent years in the light of
modern knowledge and in the view of
modern conditions of warfare this drill
conflicts with the methods which must be
used in battle so close MIG drill is our
close order drill is when you know you
see the Marines army they're like
handing the rifle back reinforced and
everything's all it's like parade type
stuff
that's what close-order drills and they
used to do more of it and now he's
saying that they do less back to the
book in the drill of the early basic
training the whole emphasis on teaching
is on teaching the soldier to respond to
spoken commands when he yet when he goes
into combat smoke and spoken commands
become impossible the human voice is
silent in the din of battle
if commands are given at all that must
be given in the form of a nudge a kick
or an arm and hand signal and in drill
the soldier also forms the habit of
acting shoulder-to-shoulder with other
men he comes to rely on being in a group
on doing what the other men do when they
do it yet in combat such close order
work would be suicidal men are on their
own men are then on their own or in twos
or freeze they must keep at a distance
from each other both to do much of their
fighting skillfully and to avoid making
crowded targets for the enemies bombs
shells or bullets this means that in
advanced training men must learn new
habits which conflict some respects of
the old that's not good the basic rule
of learning is this do it right from the
beginning because if you form wrong
habits you must unlearn them before you
can learn what is right the rule to
follow is never
therefore combat by learning to act on a
signal that cannot be given after combat
has started and then it talks about how
to increase the speed of training here's
some things to do to increase the speed
of training number one do things right
the first time
number two keep constant checks that you
know immediately whether you are doing
right or making a mistake that's a good
one that's why I like shooting steel so
much we were shot steel before you know
as soon as you as soon as you pull the
trigger the shot goes you know if you
hit it or not yeah and so it's
completely gratifying
make no unnecessary motions if you
flourish your hands or putter around
with your tools like it or not these
profitless motions will become habit to
just wanna do everything as clean as you
can do things in the same order and in
the same way stick to this rule as far
as possible avoid unnecessary leak links
in the chains of your learning this was
interesting you know well I'm not gonna
read it because it went on about
learning Morse code and how how you can
put these multiple different steps in to
learn and when in fact you could just
say that noise means this letter you
don't have to translate it to the little
things in your mind or the sounds in
your mind that dot the dot dot dash dash
dash order you don't need to translate
that in your mind that sound means this
letter and you can get there quickly
like a language is language really yeah
yeah yeah yeah like when you're fluent
in a language you don't think in English
anymore oh yes yeah I don't I've really
got but maybe gotten to that a little
bit a few parts of espanol yeah when I
was in college but I never carried out a
conversation without translating when I
was hearing which is completely lame
clunky for sure but you know that's part
of the process so thing yeah yeah number
six aim at first for smoothness of
performance rather than speed number
seven be sure to understand what you are
trying to do what final objective you
are ami aiming at that's important
people should really whoever you're
training needs to understand what
they're trying to do I found this in
early jujitsu there was a lot of lacking
in this where II didn't understand that
getting the underhooks was a thing
mm-hmm
they just understood like for this
particular move you put your arm here I
didn't understand it was a whole thing
would even better be like hey you're
always looking for the underdogs mmm
that's actually what Dean taught me Tony
he is the one that taught me that too
and this is when he was a blue belt
number eight the series of actions
rather than single moves that's good for
jiu-jitsu as well you don't just want to
learn the one you want to learn how all
those three four or five moves tie
together and how you set up the counters
and how the counter leads to another
trap nine keep on practicing
10 over learn number 11 relax
interestingly enough tell people to
relax and relax
Harger back to the book ways have been
worked out to help cut down the time
required to master subject to read and
understand a book or assignment to solve
a problem or to memorize a rule or
formula the man in the Army this is this
is about studying and I had I was like I
don't know if I'm gonna put this in
there but then all you know people are
students we will have a new job they got
to learn something and this is the most
cold-blooded way to talk about learning
the man in the army should not allow
noise or other distractions or
interruptions to put them off his work
working under such difficult
circumstances is direct training for
actual fighting conditions also there's
some annoying things going on when
you know read a book cool learn to
ignore them in the field the most in the
field the most vital and difficult
decisions must be made in the midst of
the most violent distractions and under
all sorts of physical and mental strains
the officer had to wait until he could
be free of noise or disturbance before
he could work out a problem or make a
decision would be useless in the army if
he's used to it
a certain amount of noise and confusion
may actually stimulate the army man to
do better thinking if it's convenient a
definite time of the day should be
assigned for studying the mind can be
trained to be ready for work at a
certain hour so this happens is much the
same way as you begin without being
thinking about food or some other set
time for the same reason it might be
desirable to have a certain place set
aside for study even if it is just your
bunk in a noisy barracks or tent then
the act of sitting down in that place
will immediately form habit put you in
the proper frame of mind for mental work
if you are lucky enough to have a desk
or a corner for your study don't spoil
its value by using it for relaxation or
loafing but even if they are insistently
disturbing its insistently disturbing is
nearly always possible to ignore
distractions and get down to the
business at hand the mind is an
excellent sieve net you can read the
newspapers and never see the
advertisements you wouldn't hear a
strange footsteps across the room yet
never noticed the loud ticking of a
clock on your own table the telegraph er
can sleep through the long continuous
sounding of his instrument yet wake at
once his own call when his own call
comes in with the right dots and dashes
in the same way it is possible to make
yourself deaf and blind to all sorts of
sights and sounds except those directly
concerned with the problem being studied
do you get annoyed with us when you're
trying to do what do you listen to music
when you're doing work depends on the
work but yes interesting
at first it is fatiguing to shut out
distractions you know what I'm like I
was just as I was asking but this is
what I'm like if I let something start
to bother me then it just bothers me a
tub and and for some reason if I just
don't let it bother me that it's fine
like if my my wife's in the other room
with you know my youngest daughter and
they're playing a game and they're
making noise and having conversations
about it and whatever yeah if I'm if I'm
in the wrong mind said if I don't do
what this book is telling me to do which
is just you just shut it out like like a
blank Oh legit dude is supposed to do oh
there's some noise okay or whatever yeah
just lock it up yeah otherwise it's what
weakness otherwise its major weakness
what about like snoring like you know
you're like a roommate or what but you
know yes no no I have we have a mutual
friend that when we used to go to fights
we would stay in one room and the story
would be pretty crazy but I would
normally sleep right through it
yeah yeah if I know what's happening
it's weird like Mike my crying kids when
they were babies they would make a wake
up my wife and my wife and I wouldn't
sleep right through it but if there's a
noise outside the house or whatever I'm
awake and she looks like the perfect
yeah I think the what the girl the
mother and the crying child I think
that's a genetic thing I think we're
like a crying baby's like you know a
genetic thing did you know that in Bros
I the halls of bro science eight does
that make sense
yes it does and is there part of me
because you know when when we had small
children my wife didn't work I did so
that was her roles in response and
responsibility or go to the you know do
my job during the day and whatever I was
in the Navy her roles and
responsibilities were to take care of
those kids yeah so she there's probably
a huge part of that where I'm maybe in
the beginning when the first baby was
crying and I was like oh what's that and
then eventually I just said oh she's got
it yeah yeah that makes sense got in
hand
yeah going back to the book at first it
is fatiguing to shut out distractions
you actually make your muscles tense in
your effort to attend a business later
you get so that things that distract you
no longer worry you you know it's when
I'm on an airplane you around screaming
baby on an airplane yeah no factor to me
yeah I mean this is like no factor
whatsoever what about whatever yeah we
talked about this while we were on there
okay you brought it up to I was like oh
that's creepy is that about does that
bother you
yes yeah doesn't bother me at all though
still later they help and find that you
miss them if they disappear like the man
who is startled when his clock stopped
ticking or the radio at first it
prevents you from studying but if you
keep it on continuously you make it so
you cannot study without it having set
the stage as well as possible for most
effective studying the next important
preparation is to develop absorbing
interest in the material to be mastered
it is not necessary to resort to self
delivered mental pep talks enthusiasm
grows naturally out of the realization
that a study is important in reaching a
desirable goal that it will satisfy your
curiosity and will give you a chance to
exercise some special talent isn't that
funny how that could very well be a self
pep top that those were yes Rachel you
know you do that true the chief aid to
learning however is understanding when
something makes sense when it all fits
in with what you already know that it is
easily filed away in the ready reference
system of your memory where it can be
recalled later at need learning without
understanding is hard you probably
learned the multiplication tables that
way learning with understanding may
require no effort at all
so try to understand see relationships
if chapter 8 depends on chapter 2 then
you are uncertain about chapter 2 turn
back see the dependence work it out for
yourself rather than read it again if
you learn a new scientific fact see
whether you can find instances of it in
your own experience and then when you
think you know it when you think you
know what you have studied say it all
over to yourself in your
words that tests understanding sometimes
it gets clear for the first time as you
explain it to yourself and if you can't
get it said to your own satisfaction
then chances are you really do not
understand it and what you don't
understand you won't remember that's
good information right there for the
students of the world which everyone
should be this is other good information
solving problems the method of
bird's-eye view first applies to rapid
problems solving as well haste - often
attempts people to plunge into working
out the first part of a problem or the
easy parts before the entire problem is
clearly in mind this may result in a
false start and needless work read the
whole problem through first use care and
setting the problem down if you are new
at this particular sort of problem don't
try to take shortcuts in this a little
extra time used on formulating the
problem in your mind or on paper can
save a great deal of time in finding the
solution the next step is to rapidly
review all possible methods of solving
the problem till you find the one that
seems right then try that if that file
fails to work try another that's the way
you work with a mechanical puzzle you
should use the same method on the
technical problem and this is the same
exact thing that I was saying about how
to solve like a complex tactical
scenario you take a step back you look
at what the problem is you make sure you
understand the whole problem you just
don't say oh we're gonna get shot out
from over there we're gonna change
everything and focus on them because
you're getting flanked yeah or you're
getting you're getting some recon by
fire over there so you take a step back
you analyze the situation you make sure
you understand it's the best view
possible ability and then you start
saying okay what are my options
once you figure out what your options
are you quickly assess what would the
results of those options be what's the
upside what's the downside and then you
pick one of them you go it's so funny
that exact thing not as complex but that
exact thing played itself out in my life
very recently so I got a trampoline
right you know all those big ones these
are your kids and you got to put it
together yeah
look at the whole instructions well I do
this thing where it would that they said
I forgot how they now that said the
words they these in the book right there
they you just said but basically I
looked at it I didn't understand the
whole thing I didn't read the whole
story I don't know I looked at it I was
like I understand let's see I see the
problem I'm dealing with here so I did
it and how'd that work out for it it
broke three separate times I went you
know how like at a certain point you got
to make sure you got to do something
it's like that kind so I did make sure
that the springs were aligned in a
certain way for a reason that's gonna
come up late in that you didn't know so
I'm like sure I get it I'm smart I've
put on all this through the whole thing
everything took like an hour just over
an hour to do it so I keep going to keep
going keep going now it's time to put up
like the you know the little barrier so
yeah just don't fly off the trampoline
but the spring or the the springs are
not aligned with the hooks there so I
can't put up the barriers yeah that's a
bummer isn't it it's freaking bummer
yeah and it happened again with another
thing later actually happened four times
but the fourth thing was just the little
basketball hoop and I was like it's not
worth it yeah I never put on the
basketball hoop but yeah man if I were
to read the whole thing read the whole
dang thing and I wouldn't read it would
have saved me like three hours back to
the book when you are stumped it may be
because you have taken the wrong
approach the problem is easy to get into
a rut in thinking and it's hard to shake
yourself loose from one point of view
and see and completely do it this stuff
is so simply stated that it's it you
underestimate the power of what's being
said right here yeah this stuff is
lifesavers you tend to keep going back
and repeating this same old kind of
attack that has always it failed it's
like feeling in the same it's like it's
like feeling in the same pocket six
times six times when you've lost your
cigarettes and cannot find them
especially is it hard to try new methods
when you are tired or nervous over your
failure to get the right answer at such
times it is best to close your book and
work on something else or to do
something outdoors with fresh air or
even if you can afford the time take a
nap when you come back to your problem
the new approach may come to you in a
flash and from then on the work may go
quickly and smoothly yeah I I have to
act that's one of those things I'm
pretty instinctive on a lot of things
that I do in terms of things that I talk
about in the way I actually apply them
in my life I'm pretty good at most of
them most of mug I'm not even I don't
have to consciously I can kind of look
back and go yeah see what I did and I'm
really stoked on it I can do that
especially in jujitsu I can get in a rut
and be like oh I'm just gonna do this
right here and it should work because
I've done it before and it's gonna work
this time
and I'll have to constantly like oh you
you're you're you're beating your head
against the wall you do it anymore
yeah and I'll have to do a different
approach yeah but I mean that's very
it's kind of demonstrates you humility
because you've always like every time we
roll in actually when I see you rolling
with other like really good guys it
seems like you adapt and make little
changes way quicker than most people in
for dang sure way quicker than me I feel
like I'm all that like what you just
said I feel like that's just hundred
percent me yeah ya know what I'm saying
but I'm sure I'm okay at it I mean I
know I'm okay at it but even me at this
point I'll be like oh he's not gonna put
his arm there you've tried it three
times in a row it's not working you need
to do something else yeah you can like
recognize I recognize this when I'm
beating my head up against the wall yeah
and that's not a good feeling and it's
but the great feeling is as soon as you
do something different generally you you
may not get total success but you won't
get the same how come the outcome was
failing yeah which we don't like how to
make learning stick the two basic
principles of learning anything are
interest and participation it is not
true that repetition alone is the basis
of learning something well a man who
repeats an act again and again with his
mind only half of what he is do it was
mined only half on what he's doing may
indeed learn it but he will learn it
neither quickly nor well fortunately
doing a thing and practicing it usually
we reinforce a man's interest so that
there is really only one important
principle interest at the bottom of
learning active participation is secured
by practice lectures are used only when
preliminary explanation at some length
is needed or when men cannot be put
through the work itself
you're not only told how to fire a rifle
you are helped actually to do the firing
and you work out of doors in the way
that you will later work in combat you
do under instruction what later on you
are going to have to do in combat
yourself so you got to do these things
interest is secured in a variety of way
numbered variety ways number one the
personality of the instructor is
important it should be dynamic and four
it should be a dynamic and forceful
person who appreciates the fact that
learning takes time and that some men
are slower than others he must stimulate
his men to want to learn to instruction
must finally become individual there
must be close contact between some
instructor in every soldier 3 the
relation of the learning to the problems
of combat must always be stressed for
although non-essentials aren't omitted
in army teaching is important that the
soldier should understand the basic
principles of what he is doing if he is
learning how to use a machine then he
should know how the machine works
critical
and number five the soldier must also
have full knowledge of the purpose of
what he learns of why he needs to know
it only with such knowledge can his
interest be at the highest and only with
such knowledge is he able to adapt what
he has learned to different
circumstances that arise in combat so
we've got to know why and it also says
here that all army commanders are
leaders and teachers so the if you're a
leader you are a teacher talking a
little bit here about efficiency in
training the simplest kind of learning
is to learn by trial and error but this
isn't the best the most efficient way it
wastes too much time and so the army
never uses it except in solving original
problems where one method after another
may be tried or at least imagined so
trial and error is never the best here's
a good one in battle a leader can give
orders but only brief ones
sometimes by signal the soldier
receiving such an order must also see
the battle situation right around him in
deciding how to best carry out that
order
next how to speed up training we'll to
learn a soldier's common sense tells
them that he must learn how to fight
before he meets the enemy number two
interest number three discipline
soldiers are trained to realize the
serious importance of the things they
are taught how much these things will
mean in combat later on number four
individual instruction number five
experience of success army instructors
try their best to see that each man does
a thing right the first time
even by holding his hand and putting it
through the correct movements if
necessary number six elimination of
non-essentials you've only supposed to
be learning things that you actually
need to know number seven all around
attack every possible way of reaching
the soldiers student mind is utilized
and then this instruction is immediately
put to use in action on the job soldiers
learn by doing so as far as possible
instruction has kept practical and
concrete if an instructor puts too much
emphasis on training men in the
particular details of doing a job the
soldier fails to get a clear
understanding of the results aimed at it
although men and training although in
training men in many different army jobs
adequate attention must be paid to the
detailed steps to be taken to reach the
final objective the aim itself must also
be made entirely clear to the soldier
this is cool when I train little kids in
jujitsu I'll be like you just got to get
around their legs yeah then you can tell
on that and they'll figure out how to do
it and then when they get stumped you
teach them some actual technique
otherwise he's apt to become confused in
battle if the situation changes and he
cannot follow the steps in exactly the
way he was taught in training
efficiency in the army every ounce of
the soldiers energy should be
concentrated on the defeat of the enemy
whenever he wastes his strength on any
sort of activity that does not
contribute to that one end it is an
effect casualty no where is efficiency
more important than in combat there
every man must work at the very peak of
his powers
his eyes must see better than the
enemy's eyes his ears must hear better
he must think better on this victory
depends weary weariness tired hands or
eyes or nervous system anything that
reduces the soldier's efficiency at a
critical moment in combat may cost him
his life it may cost the army a position
and advance a battle the enemy usually
refuses to recognize the end of a
workday nature often provides the only
lighting bomb holes ensure ventilation
when a soldier gets an actual combat
when he's called upon to do seems to
have no similarity at all to anything he
had ever done in a civilian job there is
no routine in battle no standardization
no monotonous repetition each moment is
a challenging new experience calling for
new decisions and fresh insight it is
hard to see where the combat soldier can
get any help at all from what he has
learned about efficiency in a factory
far from the battle zone that is why a
soldier in training must learn from the
start to cut out useless and roundabout
movements that take needless time
seconds count and a soldier's energy
counts too he can't afford to get worn
down before his job is done he must keep
his speed and accuracy up to top-notch
performance any blundering combat may be
fatal
there he may not be able to miss a name
again he may never have another
you know we get into this last little
section that we're gonna cover today
it's about fatigue but sleep that other
enemy mmm-hmm
fatigue is a fifth column' enemy that is
always ready to infiltrate an attack no
man can stick at a job for long periods
through the day and night and continued
at top-notch performance especially if
his job involves using a great deal of
strength keeping alert and making
accurate split-second decisions so you
allegedly need rest I posted the other
day sleep is the enemy and people get so
it's a song by Danko Jones mm-hmm and
it's a great song sure but and you know
I kind of do feel that way you know cuz
it's pretty easy just to fold to sleep
and you could spend all day but I know
you don't see it that way but I kind of
do know sleep is the enemy just like
food is the enemy yeah if you start
abusing it and making you know like no
man a good point just how long men can
work and continue to do their best
depends upon a great many different
things it depends first upon the man it
depends also on the type of work it
depends upon the conditions of the work
upon the food eaten upon rest obtained
during the job upon worry and excitement
and finally upon the necessity for
action a man can run fast and long if
death or the devil is behind him he can
fight hard for unbelievable lengths of
time if there can be no retreat or a
victory is in sight most hazardous is
the fatigue which comes from spurts of
extreme effort the greatest of which a
man is capable such supreme efforts
seldom if ever occurs in any job on the
homefront it does occur in sport it does
occur in battle spurred by the necessity
necessity to extraordinary violence a
man may actually put out so much effort
that he burns up his body fuel at a rate
eight times more
then the normal rate I have no idea
where they got these numbers I eight
times more that's a pretty accurate this
he cannot keep up more than a few
minutes at a time otherwise the sugar in
his blood will fail will fall to a
critically low level his heart will fail
his collapse or even death will follow
what do you think bro science right
there I mean then you make a good point
where are you I don't know go get rhabdo
yes and end but you get rhabdo you don't
like fail on the moment right your heart
doesn't fail yeah well it's all like the
first thing I thought of his like you
know in jiu-jitsu MMA where you get it
like the adrenaline dump right because
your your soul like I mean it's through
adrenaline but like it's these external
circumstances it's like you're on the
stage usually it's an inner competition
necessarily in training so you're on the
stage so it's win it's do or die
yeah on stage everyone on for die it's
not dirty but these guys are this is yes
but so you guys I was just thinking like
if this is true like when a guy gets
gassed in the UFC and he just can't go
on but then one if somebody came in
there with a machete and was like run
yeah a hack you to pieces
and I think the guy would do run yeah
but that's like another level of stress
that's do-or-die yes that's your throne
do or die out there on the UFC or
whatever and that's not accurate
no sir it's not it's very inaccurate but
as an example it feels like that's you
know like guys they're so but they're
using like probably eight times the
energy you know cuz they're so pumped up
because of they're on stage and stuff
that nerves and all that stuff so it's
like that you know it's another weird
one when so many gases or whatever and
then they end up winning and then they
get that other surge from 10 seconds ago
why don't you put that effort now
oh yeah so that that proves I wrote
about this in the Field Manual like
sometimes you got to use a motion and
sometimes you got to use logic
somebody's got to let that emotion come
out yeah so but the thing is like it
that does sound funny and look funny if
a guy like seems to be sorta gallant and
then write them literally the second he
wins he's he's running when you know but
all that is that's not like a um like it
may be a slacker there so nothing like
that that's like just the stress and
winning is like I don't know if I'd call
it a stress but I guess this is what I
heard this bro science I heard this from
people this an official thing but you
get like this boost of like hormones
like testosterone and all these crazy
hormones when you win a fight so it's
maybe to that this is like man it's not
like it's controllable you have to
actually be be confronted with a
stimulus of winning for that for you to
get that boost you know just like you're
confronted with the stimulus of the
crowd to get that overdrive scenario
we're using eight times the energy back
to the book yet such fussy fatigue does
not always make you inefficient if you
have strong enough need or desire for
action I like that right there yeah
that's that machete scenario yes
introduced sometimes I wonder if I'm
like perpetually in a state of like war
I wonder that my brain - yeah because
sometimes I can't sleep at all I believe
that yeah and because I want to get I'm
not like that all the time I mean I do
there's there's definitely days where I
sleep really soundly yeah but a lot of
times it's like no it's not happening
cuz I got stuff I gotta do were a war
over here on my end over here I
understand yes
mental work and emotional strain are
also fatiguing but the man who gets
tired from mental work or the strain of
responsibility and worry has additional
problem he may not consume the sugar in
his blood as does the man engage in a
violent physical work or combat his
blood therefore gets out of balances bro
science covenants
and the rest of sleep may not readily
restore it it's actually weird cuz it's
bro science but it makes sense yeah
that's all bro science kind of makes
sense right it is good for the man who
has been under this sort of strain to
get some sort of physical exercise a
swift game of tennis a long walk or a
turn at chopping wood a second effect of
fatigue is the tired feeling I think
that's funny
this is nature's natural protection
against over fatigue when a man feels
tired it becomes increasingly difficult
for him to go on with his job he is more
and more eager for rest and sleep less
and less able to spur himself on to go
another mile the best antidote for this
feeling of tiredness is high morale and
the example of other men it is the man
working alone who has the hardest job in
combating his own desire to lie down and
sleep but the most important effect of
fatigue is the effect it has on work
when a man is tired he doesn't he cannot
do his very best the amount of work he
is able to do falls off and the quality
of his work suffers too he does not see
it as well does not hear as well nor is
he so alert his movements may become
clumsy and bungling in loss of loss and
efficiency strange as it may seem is not
always related to feelings of fatigue a
man may feel very tired when he has not
been working particularly hard but is
merely bored or untrusted and interested
in his work or when the ventilation is
so bad that he gets dopey this is
important I think on the other hand a
man really close to exhaustion may be so
excited by his work that he's unable to
rest it does not feel tired at all oh
yeah so consider this and probably think
about this man first
yeah that's what I think and consider
this like in jujitsu right like it right
now if I were to talk enough smack to
you right now like no matter how you
feel you'd be tired you'd be a 1 hour
sleep you could be doing all this stuff
like before and whatever you could be
terrified I talking enough smack and I
challenge you to roll outside you'll
probably do it yeah there's no problem
yeah it's on but if I say okay after
this gold like run on a treadmill it's
easier it's easier yeah I'll put its
debatably easier to run on a treadmill
but man you ever run have you ever run a
shovel
like it like that I've been riding your
treadmill probably 10 times in my whole
life yeah so and you know I used to get
into treatment but man if when you get
one that boredom hits you bro you're
like I can't run or step on this damn
thing even though I could easily go
train right now it's like a bunch of
good guys you know yeah so it's like
it's that exact thing when you get bored
like just the littlest bit of fatigue is
gonna jam you up big time but even if
you're really fatigued and you're doing
something fun you'll go oh yeah for sure
that's why did you do such good exercise
so that it's fun so true men differ
considerably in the rate at which they
get tired on the same job they differ
even more in their rates of recovery
after work is over there is almost no
general rule as to what will happen
except that recovery is very rapid at
first and slows down as the resting
state is approached in fact means
however that a lot of good can be got
out of short rest and that many short
rests are better than one long one that
makes sense to me take a little power
nap students learn best if they did not
do all learning at once do not try and
cram up before examinations but study a
little and then quit for a while for a
day or two in industry efficiency is
highest when rest pauses are arranged at
frequent intervals I agree with that
although sometimes I just properly
hmm so it does not pay to overwork
workers or soldiers some fatigue is
unavoidable and much fatigue must be
undergone in the process of toughening a
soldier but chronic fatigue is not to be
found along the shortest road to victory
so don't get tired now it gets real
specific on sleep you can stay up all
night and keep awake and this I was
surprised to how accurate this reflects
me I think you'll find it accurate as
well you can stay up all night and keep
awake provided you are active provided
you keep using some muscles at least the
speaking muscles you can March all night
play poker all night fight all night and
talk all night you will likely you will
be likely to get terribly sleepy
somewhere between 0 300 and 600 unless
you're doing something exciting or
intensely interesting but you can get
through that provided you're active so
like this would happen a lot you go out
on patrol and you patrol all night to
get to a position and then it's now 3
o'clock in the morning and that's when
you get tired 4 o'clock in the morning
you I'm gonna bet that's when you get
tired and then this happens
do you actually continue on that does
not mean however that you can read or
study all night using few muscles other
than those of your eyes if you have to
study all night you may need to read out
loud or stand up to read by the time
because it's basically and that's
totally true right if you have work to
do and you're up working it's fine but
if you if you are gonna read this book
in the next 10 hours and you're falling
asleep yeah and that's one of the
reasons why if you like let's say you
have a normal schedule job like a
nine-to-five and then you want to work
out or good you get sore something after
work don't go home because when you go
home so shoot down on the cut for a
second or even if you just like you know
just talk to your wife or whatever it's
like like rather than going straight to
the gym and your that might be the best
advice you've ever given seriously like
if you want to train don't go home
let me go to the gym yeah that's a very
good advice then it goes on in it says
by breakfast time you'll be getting less
sleepy this is totally true if you stay
up and the Sawant's the sun's coming up
you can get through the next day pretty
well you may feel tired especially
you've been awake mark have especially
been marching or walking to keep awake
you won't feel fresh
you'll feel uncomfortable but other
people will not notice anything wrong
with you unless you sit down to relax
with nothing important or interesting to
do then very likely you'll doze off if
you have a job that requires accurate
movements or accurate thinking you'll
probably make no more mistakes than you
usually do so let's say hey if you stay
up for 24 hours you'd still be good to
go all next day which I know you've done
this at the muster or close to it right
we've done like an hour sleep two hours
sleep yeah yeah maybe for one day yeah
one like second day you kind of hit the
rack really yeah the second night you
won't want to stay up but you may have
to another March maybe necessary the
enemy may attack and it's the second
night and the second night is like the
first but more difficult it's harder to
keep active under your own power yet you
can if your officers are the enemy
furnish the motivation you don't want to
keep your mind on any topic very long
your thoughts and ideas will trail off
into irrelevance ease if you can
possibly get a chance to relax you will
and then you'll go to sleep you ought
not to be on sentry duty but you may
keep awake by walking or if you go off
into an inattentive days while you
continue walking by this time you are
probably getting quite irritable little
things provoke you and you may talk some
nonsense your anger does not last though
you'd rather go to sleep the day after
the second sleepless night is better
than the preceding sleepless night but
you'll be irritable rambling and
illogical and speech thought an
inattentive more than usually sensitive
to pain your eyes itch you may begin to
see double you can't sit down to read
your handwriting becomes bad and pencil
might drop from your hand you may even
begin to have hallucinations imagining
events that do not really happen as if
you begun to dream while you are still
awake
you can still be spurred to your full
mental powers in manual dexterity if
this stimulus is strong enough if your
commander demands your attention if a
shell comes over but
effect of these things doesn't last as
long as it would normally pretty soon
you are back to where you were with the
most important thing in your world is to
need the need to shut your eyes and go
to sleep
wounded soldiers coming out of combat
after many days and nights of continuing
continuous Fighting's fighting may be so
terribly in need of sleep that even the
severe pain of wounds does not keep them
from going sound asleep as soon as they
are allowed to lie down anesthetics can
be dispensed with
so there you go there's your there's
your second day and now your new your
second day oh the second full day
without sleep how long can you go
without sleep you can manage a third
night without sleep and maybe a fourth
with all the symptoms getting worse with
attention harder and harder to command
with more activity necessary to keep you
awake a psychologist once kept himself
awake for four whole days spurred only
on by scientific motive foreseeing what
would happen next with those doses of a
stimulant
Benzedrine which is like an amphetamine
which I had to look up to help he may
actually he actually kept himself awake
for eight whole days and seven nights
there was a man wants to believe that
sleep was a bad habit which ought to and
could be overcome he was given a
watchman's clock on which to record
every 10 minutes the fact that he was
awake he stayed awake almost
continuously for nine and a half days
missing only 31 out of 1380 recordings
of the 10-minute intervals of course he
got some other cat naps during the 10
minute intervals as time wore on he
became dazed he could keep appointments
at the wrong time or in the wrong place
or both he got so he could so that he
was not always sure where he was at the
end of the time he was beginning to have
hallucinations and delusions of
persecution and had become so
cantankerous that the experiment had to
be stopped he just turned she just got
so angry it had to shut it down like it
wasn't like he was gonna die he was just
real mad as you can't take this anymore
so that's pretty accurate
going back to the books sleep soon
restores the sleepy man or animal the
men who stay awake for two or three days
are generally in pretty good shape after
a 12-hour sleep and show no effects at
all after two or three normal nights
that's totally true you can get yourself
back to normal real quick yeah the whole
trouble and sleeplessness is with
attention and thus higher levels of the
brain which are necessary for attention
the soldier who loses sleep is becoming
an is becoming inefficient because he
can no longer keep his mind on the job
on any job except the one job of getting
relaxation close eyes and sleep he can
be stimulated into attention by activity
by a four tative command by danger but
the effect of the spur lasts less and
less as time lessen less time as he gets
sleepy err
when spurred he can do almost any simple
task as about as well as usual unless it
is a task that requires attention
alertness and judgment then he begins to
fail being frustrated by not being
allowed to sleep he becomes irritable
belligerent and perhaps even
unmanageable his morale goes down he's
no longer a good comrade but his
recovery will be rapid give him sleep
which is all he wants and pretty soon
he'll be back his old competent friendly
alert self that's all right in an
emergency but ordinarily soldiers should
have enough sleep they need to be alert
whether for study or combat whether
driving a truck in America or firing an
anti-tank gun in Africa or Europe enough
regular sleep from taps to first call
should be the rule except when the enemy
decrees otherwise there is no rule about
the amount of sleep that young adults
must have some get cranky and irritable
when cut down from seven hours a night
to five others do not the unit with high
morale can do with less sleep but sleepy
men tend to have low morale
these two forces work against each other
there is also there are also no rigid
rules about the details of sleep no
rules that apply to everyone alike so
and actually it's interesting because
I'm here right now on a very minimal
amount of sleep I had a meet I had to
fly to DC I had a meeting in DC it went
late and when I got done with the
meeting got back to my hotel at midnight
I had to prep this podcast I was on West
Coast time so I was like well it's only
10:00 o'clock or whatever 9 o'clock so I
just stayed awake my car pick up was at
3:00 I probably slept 40 minutes and
then well but then I did sleep on the
plane flying back from the East Coast
out to here I got at least probably
three hours of sleep there uncomfortable
or you know just not is that even sleep
we don't know what does that count as
and not try not don't have much sleep
right now I mean you look pretty good
yeah it doesn't matter you know when
people people call you can't perform I
don't know and people freak out and say
you cannot there's no way you can
perform as well when you're sleeping if
you don't have enough sleep it's like I
get it hey I'm not anti sleep if you
need to sleep man sleep as much as you
can sleep as much as you can't sleep
eight hours a day sleep ten hours a day
I don't care I'm not against you I don't
hold it against you but there's two
things number one if you have a lot of
things that you need to do and you spend
a lot of time in bed the things that you
need to do when it can happen so you may
need to get out of bed and get things to
happen number two I don't even I have a
horrible feeling if I sleep a lot yeah
not not just okay I feel bad because I
missed on doing some stuff that I'd
probably need you to do also I don't
feel more rested oh yeah okay
I don't feel more rested if I sleep
eight hours I feel sometimes worse
so yes in that he essentially said
everyone's different yes like there's no
personal because men that I'm the
complete opposite I feel way more rested
even seven hours I'm good six hours is
I'm fine six hours two days in a room
not not that's when those symptoms start
to quicken seven hours every single day
fine eight hours I feel like a blob like
imma yeah
nine hours I don't know if I would could
go nine hours more than one or two
nights in a row like just physically I
just a couple whatever I could do the
nine hours and I'd be like solids yeah
it's solid off to try some something out
off to try it out and see if I feel more
solid but you you you know like you said
people say hey you you there's no way
you can perform at your at your highest
if you're like sleep-deprived whatever
whatever
I would imagine just like how you know
how they say in here that everyone's
different like your optimum versus your
self optimum mum might be like super
small you know where you know you feel
little teeny tiny effects but your
output or the results of your output or
whatever are pretty similar they're
almost on pretty much unnoticeable even
though you could have done a little bit
better with more sleep kind of thing but
you know just like and then opposed to
me where man I go five hours of sleep
the difference between six hours asleep
in five hours asleep for me is like I
feel like a completely different person
like there's yeah all I am and there's
one time is like I remember because I
was talking to life so is the time when
life was in town I got like very hardly
any hours of sleep mmm and I remember
talking to him and thinking but I leave
Pinkham thinks I'm stupid just because I
didn't even really make sense and I
don't know if you noticed it but I
noticed it but then yeah if I got like
six or seven or whatever is cool well
for me and that freaks out but I'm not
saying don't save sleep sleep a bunch
sleep all you want
it's it's fine you don't sound very
confident or you don't sound very like
go oh it's probably because I don't
because you only got three hours of
sleep
yeah you're irritable you're too worried
I think it's because I I get that you
should sleep but I think people take
advantage of it real quick that makes
any sense they start just getting into
you know I am just gonna sleep all times
like when someone says dark chocolates
good for you old dark chocolate cake
yeah yeah and it's like well does that
include dark chocolate cakes letting
dark chocolate triple fudge ice cream
because the dark chocolate is good for
you so I'm in the game so sleep is good
for me so I'm not getting out of bed
yeah so but whatever I encourage people
to sleep and I it's not the other thing
is that it's crazy it's not like I don't
sleep I sleep I sleep it almost every
day no no I see just about every day I
go to bed at 10:00 10:30 11:00 11:30
who's somewhere in there and I wake up
at 4:30
maybe 4:20 maybe 4:30 - but that's a lot
of sleep you know that's between five
and six hours
yeah every day yeah I mean I guess for
your standards but I'm freaking out yeah
so no reason well you know I mean for
people who are sleep deprived and they
do have differences which vary yes this
much I do know I do know this for a fact
when I have less sleep I'm more
emotional oh yeah and and you know what
I actually it actually is helpful for me
oh dang yeah like I like to be sleep
deprived to some what I don't session
say said I like to sleep a little bit
less because it's more it makes more it
makes my life a little bit more on edge
which is actually what's funny is you
said that one time when you're like I
like a little bit of sleep tip
just a little bit that was weird when
you told me I was like I see what you're
saying because it kind of it's almost
like a comfort
right like if you're too comfortable
like you might be more like inclined to
relax almost kind of idea even though I
mean I can't really get down with it
because the more rested I am the more
happier I'm gonna feel and you like you
say emotional and in the book it said
irritable right or something I think
it's the same thing I'm an irritable
like the kind like I'm irritable with
like stuff not even like inanimate stuff
I don't like that my my phone isn't
connected to my girl are quick enough
I'm like what still is wrong with this
thing in my head you know that kind
stuff even but then if I'm rested but no
no factor mm-hmm maybe it won't work at
all see I I like that little bit of edge
because part of it is because things
like that never bothered me so dessert
or whatever my phone didn't connect oh
yeah so you're kind of dead inside yeah
I'd rather bring it back to life no but
a little bit of anger irritability make
it good anyways that so that's where I
want to stop for this podcast about this
book and on the next book and actually
this is like the warm-up but I think the
second half of the book is is even
better it's when it gets into the morale
it's when he gets into leadership it's
when he gets into the psychological
warfare offense and defense and so we'll
pick that up on the next podcast I
wanted to do one more little passage
from this book here it's a shorter
passage but it's just again just just a
reminder of what what war is going back
to and we go on by will Byrd here we go
we found the platoon and hardly
recognized it the sergeant was there and
McDonald but the rest were strangers
they told me that the seventy third of
the fourth division had been so caught
up that they had been withdrawn and the
85th Nova Scotia Highlanders had taken
their place the remnant of the 73rd had
been divided between us and the 13th
I got McDonald to one side and asked
questions it was
far worse than I thought the
forty-second had gone straight through
to their objective despite the sleety
snow and mud and confusion had driven
back all opposition and seized their
objective but on their left the fourth
division had been held up and a flanking
fire had taken a heavy toll Freddie was
gone he had predicted he had predicted
truly a big shell had landed beside him
killing him and burying him Charlie had
fallen in the first rush riddled with
bullets Jill the ex-policeman had fought
through to the objective and had been
killed by a sniper on the flank one
shell had wiped out Stevenson Thoreau
and Roy as they grouped by a captured
gun McMillan had been shot in the
stomach and had died after waiting hours
in the trench Billy the complainer had
fallen as he had charged a machine gun
keeping on until he was almost within
reach of the Gunners little Gilroy he
had been killed and Wescott smiley had
been wounded
Huggy the sergeant had been defied and
had been wounded at the same time and
had been taken away together
big hermann was missing they live quote
located his body a month later that
morning he had shaken hands with Freddie
said goodbye to him and then we had when
he had got going had run amok he was
found almost at the bottom of the ridge
near a battery position with eight dead
Germans about him four of them killed by
bayonet in the other platoons besides
Tommy slim and Jo had survived an IRA
and Sam and big Glenn and Eddie and
Mickey and Jerry they sat in the dugout
that night after a hard day of
rebuilding roads
each man suffering from bodily fatigue
and crawling with vermin and the clammy
chill of mud-caked clothing their faces
brooding enigmatic even Mickey's
curiously odd only their eyes moving
they would not talk about the fighting
and seemed utterly worn six months ago
we had marched eagerly bravely our tin
hats askew and with a cheeky retort for
every comment hiding whatever secret
apprehensions we had not knowing the
heavy ominous silence that follows the
burst of big shells and the cries of the
wounded not knowing what it is to scrape
a hasty grave at night and there bury a
man who has worked with you and slept
with you since you enlisted and
clearly war is hell it's a physical and
it is a psychological hell and the more
we know about it the more we should
understand that war is to be avoided as
much as humanly possible but but it also
teaches us how strong we as human beings
can be what we can overcome it teaches
us the importance of training the
importance of preparation the importance
of will not only the will to win in war
but the will to carry on and to win in
life and we all have that power we just
need to find it and to win
and I think that's all I've got tonight
so echo Charles speaking of winning I
know we are sort of trying to be on the
path of winning mentally physically
psychologically in life and on the maths
and I know that's sort of the thing
we're doing here the movement and I know
you have some recommendations for that
yes might be helpful yes there will be
helpful actually what do you got I have
well we're on the path right we got that
wait war life is war
we're asphalt whatever through World War
we're all that war yeah all that work
all that war now total war total war
that's what we're yes
total war so we be in that total war
there's little battles right so I think
people are not gonna like that what life
is war but it's so true yeah I mean it I
mean if you start looking at your life
like it's war it's gonna make you better
yeah if you look at every day as a war
on multiple fronts you know that you
have to fight where victory is the only
choice you you're gonna have a better
life actually it's really it's really
good even for someone who look I get it
the word war might trigger some people I
get it just like the word fight might
trigger some people but you could say
life is a fight it'll be a fight not
against people my suspicion is the
amount of people listening to this
podcast that is triggered by the word to
war or fight is zero zero yes I agree
that's my suspicion yeah I could be
wrong but they're severely triggered at
this point if that's where they're the
only thing we talk about is fighting in
war yes I think you're right I believe
okay
you're a Smasher so within the all-out
war there's little battles right
and in those battles one of those
battles is the jiu-jitsu ban when you do
the Juche it's you're gonna need a key
and a rash guard just to begin that's
why I think so
actually technically you could wear
basketball shorts and a tank top you
could not recommend it and I recommend
especially the basketball shorts yeah
they will be pulled down pull down
pulled up caught on people's toes yeah
sometimes just not a good plan not as
good as like yeah maybe some board
shorts if they don't miss first yeah
nonetheless this is where you get these
things from origin origin main comm
that's where you go get a rash guard get
Agee pesky in the world factually by the
way also happens to be made in America
are they the best because they're made
in America maybe maybe not but those are
two separate ways really
oh yeah best kids in the world many
different options are also crash carts
like I said also joggers yeah like I
said before but yeah a lot of clothes
apparel will say what you're missing is
jeans yes there are jeans
yeah wait can we get jeans now we should
be getting jeans now I know I have
origin jeans I know I'm in a little bit
of a preferred scenario yeah I know
people yeah so I was gonna say wait if
we can all get jeans now that's
interesting because I didn't get in yeah
well the jeans are being made at this
time yeah so they're available we'll say
denim American denim american-made best
jeans ever obviously and yeah check them
out or do you mean come also supplements
mmm best kind of supplements so I can't
come to the conclusion that's the harsh
conclusion that exercise generally
speaking is probably the best thing you
can do for yourself agree generally
speaking I'm not saying there's no
exceptions I'm not saying that
and you're not saying that throw
everything else into the dumpster
correct yes so when when it comes to
supplements okay what so what is it
what's the best kind of supplements to
take then if we understand that exercise
is the best thing you can do for
yourself what kind of supplements is it
like muscle building supplements or is
it is what I'm asking myself as I have
been driving because I Drive something
or is it the kind of supplement that
allows you to stay able to exercise at
full capacity longer but Leo's right
I know what you think yeah yeah those of
you like the joint warfare krill oil sir
you like the discipline right because
and I say this because it's not self
into it's not just intuitive you think
supplements give my body bigger or
whatever stronger but what if you do
want to get more yoke to let's say now
would you get some of that mold like you
said we don't throw everything else into
the dumpster I'm just saying this is
what I go a road and I eating whatever
and when I go on the road I go on the
trip I eat I usually really good because
I go out to a steak restaurants and I
get rib eyes yes sir and no matter what
when I come home I want to have more
yeah gonna have that mint chocolate chip
more because it's like a dessert as a
dessert without the guilt
we actually crap yeah that yeah it's
literally good for you yeah how can you
get a dessert that's actually good for
you I'll tell you out you go to Orange
in Maine calm you get mocha and if you
got kids instead of feeding kids
junk that's horrible for them you get
them some warrior kid milk you will have
kids that want to drink something that's
awesome for them yep a mile it's a meal
by the way and they will be stoked
so get your sick kids some warrior kid
Molk hasty people been asking about what
the strawberry adult milk is coming down
I told B I told B little do not mess
this up I'm like a little the strawberry
kids milk is epic it's epic yeah I said
if you mess up and the and the adult
strawberry milk is an app pick it we're
gonna
problem so be littles on the case
yeah well he's on the case yeah man it's
true also chuckle at the store it's
called Jacko's store so go to Jocko
store calm this is where you can get
shirts hoodies more rash guards all
representative of this path that we're
on and we're on the path certainly we're
gonna stay on the path we stay on the
path until the path path ends and guess
what the little answer to that little
riddle so but if you want to represent
Jocko store calm got some new stuff on
there by the way well a little new
design of the hoodies you know that one
nonetheless hey look go check it out if
you like something chocolate something
drugs enemies stickers there's some yeah
but there's bumper stickers on there
this patches on there there's more I
just designed a new rash guard it's not
like totally new it's a new rash guard
occur sent it to people getting it done
should be there and you know within the
week also I know we talked a lot of
trash to me about lightweight hoodies
yeah we're gonna do a lightweight hoodie
100% does the pipe okay Chacko
unapproved but when you see it it's
gonna be a food anyway if you like
something gets if I was gonna wear a
light way Adia would just wear a t-shirt
bro
yeah I did it but some of us you know we
like that there's like this little
intermediary position where it's not hot
it's cold but it's not cold cold you
don't like when the wind blows
consistently and you're like you know I
said lately by the grace of
decentralized command that this is
happening yes because despite what
you're saying to me yes a medium or
whatever you said a lightweight quiddity
makes no logical sense to me as a human
you know that's one of the many
differences between me and you can I
think that there are a lot of people out
there who support me on this decision
which is wack we will track and see if
anyone buys lightweight
going to the numbers okay I understand
also these women's never present them to
the people yeah cool well there it is
yeah anyway choco store calm there's
some women's stuff on there that it
there's cool stuff you like something
get some that's good way to represent
for sure also choco white tea
mm-hm if you want to deadlift 8,000
pounds if you're not already okay this
is the reason or one of the reasons
unless you're already a tea drinker even
if you're not a teacher good because I
wasn't teaching Korean I drink chocolate
white tea so I am a teacher in quartet
technically this is the original this is
like the first thing what I'm gonna make
something I'm gonna make this tea oh the
person tea is the og of fraud against
the og product yeah I had some on the
way over here yeah you know it's funny
man if you cut because I was a little
bit chilly I wanted some warm tea I
could have used a little it's
interesting how all these products is
all stuff that you use so you're like
you're like walking not walking but
you're just sort of existing you're like
hmm instead of like you know getting
this stuff let me just mix it and it
turns out I make all your own stuff well
the thing is if you're gonna be I'm
picky that's my problem
I'm picky about what I like and what I
don't like yeah and so yeah well I'm
straightforward but I'm picky I want
this specific thing a specific way and
you can't buy what I want or you
couldn't you couldn't buy what I want
now you can this is what I want makes us
like everything like the JIT like
victory MMA and fitness
our gym why is that why does it exist
because we want it to have the way we
want things to be you can't just you
can't go to someone else's gym and
expect it to be the way you want it yeah
you can't buy some supplement off the
shelf and expect it to taste the way you
want it to taste it's gonna taste the
way some random person in some other
area wanted it to taste they don't know
what tastes good
well and they're gonna think once they
figure they had supporting that they're
just trying to make the maximum profit
margin so they're putting
whatever yes make totally makes if
you're gonna make something then if you
have to you if you want to use something
why not make it the way you want it
origin genes by the way same thing yeah
the way I want them to be made the way
Pete like so made yeah you know in
America so anyways yeah that's how we
end up doing this stuff boom
yeah good I'm glad you did by the way oh
and there's some people we joked about
subscribing to the podcast I saw some
comments that people didn't head and
subscribe to the podcast until the last
show this dude was like I listen to a
hundred and c63 episodes and I never
subscribe to the podcast until you said
and joked about who would listen to a
hundred and sixty three episodes and not
subscribe to the podcast and he said
that was me huh so there might be one
other person out there that hasn't
subscribed to the podcast or hasn't
subscribed to the YouTube channel or
hasn't subscribed to the warrior kid
podcast so if you haven't subscribed to
those things do so wait what do you mean
you stand corrected you're the one that
always says like there might be someone
that's and I didn't believe you I think
I don't know if I'd ever say for
subscribing but it was ya know I always
said or feel that it seems obvious yes
to subscribe but subscribe and I always
thought that that was dumb yeah and I
thought to myself who could listen to
this podcast over and over again and not
subscribe to it but that rubbed off on
me and I started to feel that way in
fact cuz right now I'm trying to search
my feelings and I do feel that way like
yeah just why are you telling people to
subscribe but now what I'm saying is we
got reports back from the field
people that didn't subscribe yet 162
podcast deep huh and now 164 podcast but
if you must subscribe to a podcast
subscriber if you check out the YouTube
channel by the way the YouTube channel
Echo's videos are on there he's real
proud of them
either you're proud or place little
things exploding some people think it's
too much
well I'm some people think sometimes
you're right in there it's a dichotomy
you got a balance that I caught me no
you know effects too many effects
yeah well it's there's varying levels of
appropriateness with effects so at some
point I want you to purposely make a
video that's completely you take
whatever I've said on this podcast
that's over-the-top anyways and just
make the most over-the-top video that's
a good I remember one time I said don't
sleep eat steak train her that's what
that's what the video should be sorry
about that just guys with broken legs
crawling out on the mat with a stinging
out of their mouth you know like that
kind of thing over the top everything
exploding fire because a lot of times
your explosions don't have fire a lot of
times they're just smoking more more
like smoke and dust yeah you keep it
dark yeah they're less explosions more
just like just rent like various levels
of destruction so check that out check
out the warrior kids soap and Irish Oaks
ranch calm young Aiden making or your
kids soap check out psychological
warfare little bits of information to
help you overcome momentary weakness
I'll tell you how to do it it's not real
complicated yeah but it is effective you
know check Amazon music that's where you
can get it yeah and iTunes you know
where do you buy mp3s a3 that's what's
called psychological warfare good one
very much also you want to subscribe to
the warrior kid podcast like I said that
I'm glad you're emphasizing it though
well yeah I thought you didn't say that
okay that's nice nonetheless yeah yeah
it's a good one that's a good one for
you and the kids
both these guys because they're they're
they're good lessons but they're super
basic just like this just like this book
man
very much so also on it on it comm go
there slash job go on it calm slash
Drago this is where you can get
kettlebells add to your home gym add to
your capability rings add to that
capable I just got some the Stormtrooper
one Star Wars Street uh-huh Brad don't
hate on that rez third their dough
unless through a lot of good stuff on
there good fitness stuff doing New York
of stormtroopers do you actually think
of like badass
yeah no cuz I always think of them as
just things that get shovels yes that
and that is true that is true but are
they humans yeah they're people they're
troopers actually I think they're clones
okay people so there's that's why
they're just fodder they just get killed
by laser beams all the time in the movie
yes but when you see a stormtrooper
kettlebell it's pretty cool okay and
there's a drug Vader one two there's an
Iron Man one and there's a the bubble
fat guy with Jango Fett or both oh no no
they were the same element so
nonetheless are they related they're one
is where the clone came from if I'm not
mistaken I I don't know I might have got
my Star Wars mythology mixed up but
nonetheless they are kettlebells now on
it makes them in there dope a lot of
cool stuff on there on it Dom flash
choco we got Mikey in the Dragons book
that's available right now for every kid
that you know get a Mike in the dragon's
way the warrior kid and way the warrior
kid to Mark's mission those are books to
show your kid how to be on the path and
now we have coming warrior Kid 3 which
now has a subtitle and the subtitle is
where there's a will so he has to dig
deep in this book learns a little bit
about digging deep he also learns a
little bit about humility he learns
about ego for the first time his Eagle
it starts getting involved so check out
those books that I will let you know
when warrior kid 3 is available for
pre-order which we're gonna be a little
bit more efficient this time when we do
pre-order so we don't get into the Mikey
in the dragon situation where people
have to wait a little extra
time to get the book when it comes out
so books me I'll let you know when
that's ready the Field Manual discipline
goes freedom Field Manual available
right now I was with a buddy of mine
that say in in the finance world and has
you know one of those I guess would be a
stereotypical office of the finance the
investment bankers new you know I'm
talking about everything clean white New
York City type that off yes and he
showed me a picture in there as you walk
in this beautiful clean office entryway
it's not even an office it's like a
thing office for yeah yeah yeah one of
those and there's a white table it's a
big white table you know it's probably 8
by 8 mm there's one book by itself
yeah the Field Manual and he says and he
says his his front office grown the
other day said everyone that comes in
looks at that book and says what is this
where does come from where did you get
this every single person so that's the
Field Manual discipline equals freedom
Field Manual get it for anyone that
needs to little help being on the path
and you know who needs helping on the
path
everybody extreme ownership first book I
wrote with my brother life babban
leadership lessons from the battlefield
and then we wrote the dichotomy of
leadership which gives some guidance on
how to be more balanced as a leader
because if you get out of balance as a
leader you go extreme in one direction
or the other in a multitude of various
dichotomies you will rip your team apart
which is not good so dichotomy
leadership and get that one we also got
national on front which is our
leadership consultancy and that's what
we do is we solve problems through
leadership it's me it's lave Bab and JP
to nail Dave Burke Flynn Cochran Mike
Sorelli Mike bye MA go to echelon front
comm if you want us to come and work
with your company get your leadership
align and get your entire organization
on the path to victory
hit us up we have the muster which is
our leadership event 2019 we're doing it
may 23rd and 24th in Chicago we're doing
September 19th and 20th and Denver and
we're doing December 4th and 5th in
Sydney Australia are you going to
Australia with us yes okay
so that's what's happening every event
that we've done has sold out and when I
say sold out I mean we're personal
friends of mine are saying hey handsome
late but can you say just I just need
three seats you know for me and my
girlfriend and my buddy we're gonna go
and I'm like actually no I can't there's
no more seats and the fire code will not
allow any more human beings in there so
these are all are gonna sell out
there'll be no alibis it's like well in
the military to held safe rounds for
alibis meaning like I got an extra round
Hey just want one more yeah it's not
gonna have yeah so and don't get mad if
that does happen you know Oh joke will
you you know can I help you we have to
throw a fire marshal so if you want to
come sign up early extreme ownership
calm I'll tell you what the Australian
one is gonna be it's gonna sell out
quick because I think there's 450 seats
that is not a lot and when I did a book
signing up and Brizzy up in Brisbane
Australia Brisbane there was a ton of
people there that flew to Brisbane mmm
to hang out for five minutes you know
get a book signed so that one in Sydney
is gonna be sold out quick so jump on
there if you want to calm down if you're
a trooper in the game come to the muster
extreme ownership calm EF online now
active what is it it's interactive
leadership training online it actually
puts you into scenarios that you have to
figure out that you have to make
decisions combat scenarios business
scenarios
role-playing scenarios dealing with
people it's it's awesome training it
will really ingrain the principles of
extreme ownership the laws of combat the
dichotomy leadership it'll and grain
them into you it'll make you better
leader that is EF online.com whether
you're a company that wants to use it as
an enterprise service or you just an
individual that wants to get in the game
deeper go to EF online.com and we also
have EF overwatch where we're taking
proven combat leaders from Special
Operations and combat aviation
communities and we're putting them into
businesses that need experienced proven
leaders go to EF over watch.com if
you're on either side of that
calculation whether you're a vet that
needs work or whether you're a company
that needs leaders let us know EF
overwatch comm and if you want to talk
to us or you want to share a good book
with us like somebody shared the
psychology for the fighting man with me
on the interwebs and that's what we can
be found on Twitter on Instagram and on
Facebook EKKO is at Echo Charles in I am
at Jocko will Inc and of course thanks
to all of those who serve our military
personnel police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs
correctional officers Border Patrol all
first responders all of you that put on
a uniform and protect us from evil in
the world we can only do what we do
because you do what you do so thank you
and to everyone else out there that is
listening remember to train hard
do your best to prepare stay in the
fight and even though you might not feel
like it sometimes you can drive on you
can push through
you can deal with unimaginable adversity
as long as you keep getting up every day
moving forward in getting after it so
until next time this is echo and Jocko
out